Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Prittler und äh heute ist der
erste Januar zwanzig einundzwanzig
und äh wir schütteln das alte Jahr von uns und äh geben uns der Hoffnung hin. Alles würde besser werden. Das werden wir jetzt heute herausfinden, denn heute ist natürlich wieder Colona Weekly angesagt und ich sage erstmal hallo zu Pavel.
Äh hallo Tim und frohes neues Jahr.
Ja, frohes neues Jahr, das äh wünschen wir uns natürlich alle und ähm die Hoffnung stirbt ja, wie wir wissen, immer zuletzt.
Ach zwanzig einundzwanzig wird super, noch viel besser als zwanzig zwanzig. Ich meine, das war ja schon eigentlich ein ganz gutes Jahr, oder? Ich mein.
Es hatte viel Lehrreiches und ähm durchaus ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal jetzt optimistisch betrachten möchte.
Positiv äh da gab's eine Menge zu lernen, da gab's da ist endlich mal was passiert,
Finde das ja eigentlich auch immer ganz geil, wenn so eine Gesellschaft mal so ein bisschen disrapted wird so und aus ihrem Trott rausgerissen wird. Ich meine, muss nicht dann unbedingt zur Folge haben, dass so viele Leute davon sterben, aber.
Ja, aber.
Die Selbstverständlichkeiten werden dann anders.
So ein bisschen Apokalypse ab und zu äh glaube ich braucht man auch als gesellschaftliches Korrektiv vermute ich mal, wenn Dinge schief laufen.
Ja, das denke ich auch.
Dann gucken wir nochmal, wie weit wir jetzt diese Apokalypse äh vielleicht schon in Ronn äh sind oder wie die Wetten so stehen,
Ja und wie könnte man das besser starten als mit einem Blick auf die Zahlen, den wir glaube ich heute am wenigsten trauen.
Seit lan.
Ja, in der Tat ähm.
War ja schon absehbar oder zu erwarten, dass wir halt über Weihnachten in so eine Art Nebelbank einfahren, was jetzt die Zahlen.
Angeht, was die Erhebung angeht und insofern bringt es irgendwie kaum,
etwas jetzt über aktuelle Zahlen
zu reden, aber wir werden's trotzdem einfach mal erwähnen, um das in den Kontext zu setzen, also die Zahlen sind seit
Weihnachten seit dem zwanzigsten ungefähr beziehungsweise ja am zwanzigsten sind nicht mehr weiter gestiegen, der sieben Tagesschnitt und äh so seit einer Woche
ist der halt jetzt deutlich gefallen,
aber die neu infizierten Zahlen spiegeln halt nicht das Infektionsgeschehen wieder, weil ähm demnach äh würden nämlich,
alle Bundesländer im Moment oder fast alle Bundesländer fallende Zahlen haben und Deutschland auch. Aber wenn man dann mal einen Blick auf die
Testzahlen wirft, dann stellt man fest, dass wir den krassesten wöchentlichen Rückgang von Tests äh in der Geschichte des äh Korona,
Virus-Testings äh hatten, nämlich von eins Komma sechs Millionen auf,
ja eine Million sechzigtausend ungefähr.
Und das sind einundfünfzig Prozent weniger Tests in der zweiundfünfzigsten Kalenderwoche, also es war die Woche vom einundzwanzigsten bis zum siebenundzwanzigsten. So
obwohl jetzt fünfzig Prozent weniger Tests gemacht wurden sind.
Die Zahl der positiven Tests nur um fünfunddreißig Prozent zurückgegangen und gleichzeitig die positiven Quote um zehn Prozent gewachsen, so.
Heute mal ein kurzer äh Nachfrage zwischendurch von eins Komma sechs auf eins sind einundfünfzig Prozent.
Mehr ich rechne da ich mit derselben Formel sozusagen Anstieg und Rückgang rechne sind es halt einundfünfzig Prozent vom Endwert äh immer.
Also sagen, es ist okay, es waren nicht ein und es ist nicht um einundfünfzig Prozent, sondern von hunderteinundfünfzig auf hundert Prozent zurückgegangen. So könnte man's dann vielleicht genauer ausdrücken.
Weil ich meine, ich habe halt diese fortlaufende Zeitreihe und da musst du halt entweder durch den Vorwochenwert oder durch den aktuellen Wochenwert teilen, je nachdem, auf was du die Prozentzahl beziehen willst. So
Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen mühsam,
habe ich natürlich nicht gemacht, je nachdem, ob die gewachsen oder gefallen sind, müsstest du dann halt äh entweder durch den Vorwochenwert oder durch den aktuellen Wert teilen,
Aber gute Nachfrage von hunderteinundfünfzig Prozent auf hundert gefallen, also knapp äh ja über einen Drittel
ungefähr.
Okay, aber ich meine, sechshunderttausend, rund sechshunderttausend weniger bei eins Komma sechs Millionen, das ist auf jeden Fall eine Hausnummer äh mit anderen Worten und was hast du gesagt, die positiven Quote ist auch deutlich gestiegen dabei, ne.
Ja um äh zehn Komma sieben fünf Prozent, also ist jetzt eine Prozentzahl von der Prozentzahl. Also von ja elf Komma fünf sieben auf zwölf Komma neun sechs aber.
Okay, aber dreizehn, dreizehn Prozent positiven Quote, das ist auf jeden Fall der höchste Wert, den wir jemals hatten und nochmal deutlich höher als letzte Woche und da,
drückt sich im Prinzip schon das aus, was wir äh vorher schon gesagt haben. Wir haben zu wenig Tests. Wir erfassen das Infektionsgeschehen nicht annähernd. Das drückt sich in dieser positiven Quote aus und das kann man im Prinzip an der geringen Zahl an Tests auch ablesen
spricht die Weihnachtsfeiertage haben genau den Effekt gebracht, den wir erwartet haben, nämlich weniger Leute lassen sich testen oder weniger Leute konnten einen Test finden, also,
Ja, also haben's nicht äh geschafft irgendwann zu finden, habe ich auch verschiedene Geschichten gehört, dass das alles gar nicht so einfach war.
Ja, Testzentren würden jetzt auch geschlossen und äh wenn man jetzt einen Test haben will äh und,
nicht ganz ganz enge Kriterien äh erfüllt, dann muss man halt selber zahlen. So gibt's irgendwie Anspruch äh auf einen Tests der von der Krankenkasse bezahlt wird, hat man ja nur, wenn
Ärzte
sagen, das entscheiden, dass diese Person jetzt nach den strengen Kriterien getestet werden muss, sondern auch von verschiedenen Seiten gehört, dass die halt extrem streng sind, dass Kinder zum Teil.
Äh gar keine Tests kriegen, so und äh ja und wenn man keine Symptome hat, dann sowieso nicht, dann muss man eh bezahlen.
Ja also wahrscheinlich sogar Symptome plus irgendwie ähm.
Entweder eine äh rote Anzeige in der Corona Warnapp, die das scheint jetzt weit klar zu sein, dass wenn du da eine rote Anzeige hast, dass du dich.
Dann auch auf Krankenkassenkosten testen lassen kannst. Ja, aber wie man's auch dreht und äh wendet, so.
Ja im Moment.
Kann man nicht wirklich genau sagen, wie sich die Infektion entwickelt haben, aber äh was man auf jeden Fall sagen kann ist, dass äh sich,
bestenfalls äh der Anstieg äh verlangsamt hat, aber eigentlich.
Deutet 'ne steigende positiven Quote immer darauf hin, dass das Infektionsgeschehen sich auch eher
ausgeweitet hat. Aber das kann man halt nicht
in jeder Situation und nicht in allen Fällen sagen, weil das hängt dann wieder von anderen Faktoren.
Auch zum Beispiel wie viele der Tests jetzt durch Schnelltests äh vorher veranlasst wurden und wie sich das in verschiedenen Altersgruppen,
entwickelt und so. Also deswegen,
ja kann man jetzt nicht einfach hingehen und diese drei Zahlen jetzt nehmen und hat dann einen perfekten Korrekturfaktor für,
tatsächliche Infektionsgeschehen, weil das ist sondern auch regional unterschiedlich machen. Also ja, wir fahren im Nebel.
Was denkst du denn, wie lange es jetzt dauert, bis wir diese Abtastlücke aufgefangen haben.
Eigentlich sollte das in den nächsten Tagen sich normalisieren in anderen Ländern
die auch eine Weihnachtsdelle hatten die sind da schon durch
bei ihrer Berichterstattung, aber äh das lässt sich dann vielleicht auch nicht äh vergleichen. Aber eigentlich müsste sich das also spätestens nächste Woche müssten wir halt
wieder einigermaßen verlässliche Zahlen haben, wobei natürlich jetzt noch Silvester dazu kommt, äh mit einem Wochenende dran. Also,
Gut, wir werden's halt sehen, wenn sich die Testzahlen stabilisiert äh haben, aber wenn,
jetzt dann wieder ungefähr genauso viele Tests gibt oder wieder ein paar Tests mehr, dann kann man schon mal ähm das ein bisschen genauer festlegen, also in einer in einer Woche ungefähr weiß man ein bisschen genauer
Bescheid. Aber ja es äh also.
Ich würde sagen so mit meinem jetzt Zahlengefühl nach neun Monaten äh ist, dass sich das Infektionsgeschehen.
Tatsächlich er,
schon etwas verlangsamt hat, die die Ausbreitung, also das ist schon auch einen Effekt gibt,
der das Infektionsgeschehen gedämpft hat, wie stark der ist, weiß ich nicht so gefühlt würde ich sagen
ähm dass sich der Anstieg
erstmal äh wieder verlangsamt, hat so äh auf um die null, also mit einem R von eins tatsächlich, also wie der Rückgang noch starker Anstieg,
aber was wir natürlich auch noch nicht in den Zahlen drin haben äh so richtig ist das Weihnachtsgeschehen, dass die Auswirkung der Weihnachtsfeiertage das werden wir aber so in den nächsten,
ja, Tagen, also weil halt jetzt blöderweise Wochenende ist, wir haben das halt ähm ja eher,
Dienstag, Mittwoch, nächster Woche spüren, was da insgesamt abgegangen ist.
Ja, also ich meine, die Weihnachtstage jetzt vor einer Woche war der fünfundzwanzigste, so dann zieht sich das halt dann vielleicht auch bis zum sechsundzwanzigsten, siebenundzwanzigsten hin, dass wir da sozusagen erhöhtes Infektionsgeschehen haben, hätten haben können.
Oder vielleicht gehabt haben, weil sie nicht so und wenn man dann nochmal zwei Wochen draufrechnet.
Dann wären das halt so der zehnte Januar herum, wo sich das dann eigentlich erst so richtig zeigt mit Erkrankungen.
Naja, so acht bis zwölf Tage.
Nach Infektion kann man sagen geht diese Infektion in die Zahlen ein irgendwo in der Gegend.
Manche früher, manche schneller, aber so typischerweise zeigt sich der Höhepunkt des Effekts so nach zehn, elf Tagen.
Gut, das wäre dann der siebte, also hätten wir quasi schon eine Chance
beim nächsten Corona Wickly quasi am achten Januar müsste es sich eigentlich schon langsam andeuten und man kann zumindest davon ausgehen, dass was wir jetzt an sinkenden Zahlen äh sieht sich dann doch stark relativieren wird. Und selbst wenn.
Selbst wenn jetzt diese Zahlen alle wahr werden, was man, glaube ich, sicher sagen kann, dass sie das nicht sehen, ne,
trotzdem in Deutschland einen nach deiner Tabelle gehe von ungefähr null Komma acht fünf.
Und sogar das würde nicht ausreichen.
Ja, also sagen wir so mit einem R von null Komma acht fünf werden wir zumindest äh deutlich auf dem Weg nach unten.
Ja, aber es würde trotzdem noch mindestens einen Monat oder zwei dauern, bis das dann sozusagen uns in irgendwelche sicheren Fahrwasser bringt. Und da sind wir halt auch noch nicht und äh wo wir genau sind, werden wir noch sehen. Naja, also alles noch nicht so toll.
Eher ich, ich würde sagen, wir sind eher irgendwo um die eins rum im Moment, was auch eine, ich sage mal, eine Verhalten,
positive Nachricht äh wäre, weil dann zumindest äh die große Explosion ähm,
an Infektionen durch Weihnachten dann eher ausgeblieben,
wäre und wenn das der Fall ist, das wäre, dann wiederum einen Hinweis äh darauf, dass es dann doch nicht die privaten Kontakte
sind, die das Infektionsgeschehen treiben, sondern eher die Kontakte im öffentlichen Raum, in den Schulen und in den Berufen, wenn das sagen, wenn wir jetzt feststellen, dass hier tatsächlich,
statt sagen wir Weihnachtsexplosion jetzt eher eine Weihnachtsdelle haben die real ist.
Schwierig zu sagen oder es haben sich wirklich alle am Riemen gerissen.
Ja, das ist eher unwahrscheinlich meint, das die die Büllerei gestern war ja glaube ich ein ganz deutlicher Indikator dafür, wie sehr sich denn Leute jetzt ja an irgendwie Dinge halten,
oder eben auch nicht und da kann man nicht sagen, gut, es war noch erstaunlich
viel Böllerei dafür, dass es eigentlich kein Feuerwerk zu kaufen äh gab, müssen entweder die Keller voll gewesen sein oder
hat einfach äh ziemlich viel ähm ja Schwarzhandel stattgefunden, hat man ja auch auch gehört, aber auf jeden Fall.
Unglaublich festhalten. Ähm es hat erstaunlich viel geknallt so. Manchen gingen mir wirklich sehr viel, aber ähm.
So die Zahlen und auch wenn man jetzt mal auf die Gehwege oder Straßen guckt äh ist,
kaum Müll zu sehen während sonst in den Jahren, du kaum einen Meter gehen kannst hier in den
konntest auf dem Gehweg ohne überall irgendwie kaputte Flaschen, Scherben oder Feuer vor allem Feuerwerksreste gehen und
auch was die Feuerwehren und Notdienste sozusagen äh hatten, die nun achtzig prozentigen Rückgang so gegenüber anderen Jahren bei Einsätzen und Zahl der Verletzten. Aber,
es gab eben dann doch die zwanzig Prozent, sage mal Hardcore-Feierer, die.
Nicht nur sich nicht einfach äh sagen,
daran gehalten haben, beziehungsweise war ja nicht illegal komplett, wobei man auch sehen konnte, dass die Zahl von illegalen Feuerwerken äh auch
Ähm ja, nicht unerheblich war. Ich meine, das sieht man halt vor allem dann ähm.
Man kann das den Dingern einfach ansehen, ob da jemand
F2 oder im eigentlich erlaubnispflichtiges Feuerwerk aus Polen abbrennt und da war eine ganze Menge dabei. Definitiv. Aber
trotzdem äh äh Rückgang, also sondern sagen viele Leute,
waren vernünftiger und äh aber offensichtlich ist auch in normalen Jahren gerade in Berlin es,
einfach so ein Feuerwerksover Kill, dass wenn man das um,
achtzig Prozent reduziert immer noch verdammt viel an Knallerei übrig bleibt ja.
Reicht auf jeden Fall auch noch.
Ja, wenn man das jetzt äh,
als als Analogie äh nimmt so, wollen wir mal sagen, nimmt man wieder die üblichen achtzig, zwanzig, achtzig Prozent vernünftige Leute und zwanzig, die sich einfach nicht scheren, beziehungsweise sogar dann,
extra Anstrengungen unternommen haben, um äh in den Besitz von Feuerwerk zu kommen und des Abbrennen zu können.
Kommen wir zurück zu den Zahlen, also selbst bei diesen irgendwie reduzierten Zahlen sind trotzdem so ein paar Ausreißer dabei, die ich äh ganz schön bemerkenswert finde. Wenn man da eine Landkreisliste anschaut.
Gibt's da ein Kreis, wo ist denn das eigentlich genau? Vogtlandkreis. Ähm.
Ja, ist alles so Erzgebirge, ne. Ähm da sieht's nicht gut aus und die bringen ja tatsächlich eine eine sieben Tage Instit von über eintausend auf die Waage.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das überhaupt schon mal hatten.
Nee, ich kann mich da auch nicht erinnern, dass wir schon mal was über tausend hatten, wobei ja äh da halt auch.
Paar Nachmeldungen äh.
Dabei sind, dass RKI wirft, glaube ich, in seiner Institutionberechnung einfach mal neunzehn Prozent der Fälle weg, sodass er offiziell nur achthundertzweiundzwanzig sind, aber tatsächlich.
Wurden halt dort jetzt äh zweitausenddreihundertundeins Fälle in den letzten sieben Tagen gemeldet äh ans RKI.
Ja und das ist äh doch eine ganze Menge Holz, ne, nochmal zur Erinnerung, diese Instituz, ja, tausendzehn steht jetzt hier in deiner Tabelle. Bedeutet von hunderttausend.
Eintausend oder anders ausgedrückt, ein Prozent der Bevölkerung hat sich in der letzten Woche infiziert.
Ja
Jetzt können wir da noch irgendeine Dunkelziffer dazurechnen, kann man auch erstmal weglassen, weil es auch so schon schlimm genug. Und der Vogtlandkreis,
führt, wenn ich das richtig sehe, auch insgesamt glaube ich an, oder? Nee, das ist der Erzgebirgs äh Kreis, der noch ein bisschen.
Schlimmer ist.
Moment, in absoluten Zahlen.
Tote.
Ja genau, also in Tote, gut, dass Herr Vogtlandkreis noch nicht äh so weit da, aber der Erzgebirgskreis, der ist ja da auch gleich um die Ecke.
Die haben halt äh eine Totalinstitenz von vier Komma ja viertausendneunhundert. So, oder? Also hat Salopp gesagt, fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung sind da schon offiziell als infiziert registriert.
Da frisst sich das Virus einfach in einer Geschwindigkeit gerade durch Sachsen, das das ist nicht schön.
Ja. Und du kannst von einer Dunkelziffer zwischen drei und sechs ausgehen im im Moment. Also eigentlich musst du die mal mindestens mal drei nehmen.
Die Zahlen, so dass es dann immer noch eine konservative Schätzung des realen Infektionsgeschehens.
Also man kann irgendwie davon ausgehen, dass so knapp ein Fünftel sich dort irgendwie schon angesteckt hat.
Das ist krass. Ja, da können wir dann auch später äh nochmal dazu, ob denn irgendwie wir überhaupt mit den Impfstoffen noch hinterherkommen.
Oder ob nicht schon alles abgegrast wurde vorher, ne? Ob das Löschmittel äh erst kommt, wenn die Bäume schon alle runtergebrannt sind.
Gibt's sonst noch Sachen, die so aus den Zahlen sich herauslesen lassen, die vielleicht noch wert wären, angesprochen zu werden.
Vielleicht eine Sache so die Inzidenz in Berlin halt in den Altersgruppen.
Kann man euch noch sagen, dass nach wie vor in Berlin so die Altersgruppe achtzig plus halt eine Institenz hat, die zwischen zweieinhalb und acht Mal so hoch ist wie bei den anderen Altersgruppen.
Äh das lässt also weiterhin nichts Gutes erwarten für dann die Entwicklung der Todesfälle. Und da hatten wir.
In Berlin dann zwar auch jetzt einen Rückgang zu verzeichnen seit dem zwanzigsten
aber das ist vermute ich mal auch im Wesentlichen wie Berichtsbedingt, aber ja Genaueres dann in einer, in einer Woche, wir sind halt im Nebel.
Im Moment.
Nebel, genau. So, vielleicht noch mal ein kurzer Blick auf die internationale äh Situation. Man meint es ja ein paar anderen hätte sich schon eine Normalisierung eingestellt.
Ja, wenn man zum Beispiel mal Tschechien oder Portugal sich ansieht, die haben halt so eine schöne Weihnachtsdelle. So geht's einmal runter und sind jetzt wieder aber auf dem Niveau so
von von vor der vor der Delle zurück bei Portugal kann man auch ähnliches beobachten ähm ja
andere Länder, ja, kleine Länder, Monaco.
Kleine Rinder muss man eigentlich immer rauslassen, dass da ist es immer so verzehrt auch Lichtenstein und sowas, das das bringt irgendwie herzlich wenig.
Ja. Aber gut, es war eigentlich ja Slowenien ging's auch Schweden,
gesagt, ja also im Moment haben wir nicht in allen Ländern so Weihnachtsdellen äh gerade, aber ja, schon in vielen, muss man sagen.
Ja, Schweden hat das.
Ja, in der Schweiz geht's jetzt auch irgendwie seitwärts seit.
Eigentlich fast über einem Monat, hm interessant, ja. Okay, also ja international auch so ein bisschen unklar, die Situation.
Also so richtig Erfolge feiert in Europa auch gerade kein Land. Das das ist irgendwie erstaunlich.
Und würde ich sagen, ist so am krassesten, da gab's zwar auch über Weihnachten so eine,
kleine Abflachung, aber da gehen die Zahlen auch jetzt seit einer Woche oder eigentlich länger seit einem Monat kennen die Zahlen in UK eigentlich nur eine Richtung und das ist nach oben.
Ab ab in Dua, hm.
Ja und.
Das hat vermutlich auch stark mit der neuen äh UK-Virusvariante zu tun, was jetzt vielleicht eine gute Überleitung äh wäre zu dem Thema, oder?
Ja, der, der UK Varis, gab's einen schönen Tweet irgendwie wieder so ein.
Hast du auch gesehen? So ein irgend so ein so ein Tory MP der sich wieder rüber beschwert hat, dass er es jetzt irgendwie alle den das UK Wares nennen, weil das das wäre doch hier nur zuerst äh aufgefunden worden und was würde ihnen denn einfallen.
Sich so einen alten Tweet von ihm geschnappt, wo er dann so China war, wo es China warus.
Genau.
Pagiert hat, also.
Ja, ich habe zufällig äh sogar auch einen einen Replay äh äh darauf äh,
getwittert äh der im Wesentlichen gesagt, nee, ich finde, die Bezeichnung UK Virus eigentlich ganz passend, weil zum einen sieht es wohl schon,
so aus, aber das ist, das habe ich jetzt,
die Quelle habe ich jetzt nicht überprüft, aber äh dass irgendwie ein Immungeschwächter
Mensch aus Kent wohl, äh da der Patient null war, bei dem sich die
Mutation entwickelt hat und auf jeden Fall deutet aber auch die Tatsache, dass es sich hier den UK so weit ausgebreitet hat, daraufhin, dass es dort auch seinen Ursprung
genommen hat, ja. Ähm und.
Insofern und man sagen kann, okay, erstens UK hat es zugelassen, dass wie viele andere Länder auch, aber,
dort insbesondere, dass die Zahlen halt hochgehen, damit hat man im Virus genug Gelegenheit gegeben, zu motieren. Man hat das Virus auch
erst erkannt oder diese neue Mutter, als es zu spät war, als es sich zu weit
ausgebreitet hat und man hat es nicht eingedämmt und man hat auch den Export dieses Virus nicht eingedämmt. Also wenn dann verdient äh dieses schon den Namen UK Virus definitiv.
Ja, also ich hab,
es es kam schon, als wir das das letzte Mal behandelt haben in Kommentaren auf Twitter und so weiter auch eine ganze Menge äh Feedback unter anderem der Verweis auf ein äh Video von Vincent äh Racaniello,
Weiß nicht, ob dir der Name etwas sagt.
Nein.
Ja, das ist so einer der äh Viren äh Pepse in den USA,
unter anderem seit Ewigkeiten den Podcast This Week and Vierology macht.
Der, äh, natürlich, wie man sich vorstellen kann, in diesem Jahr einen enormen Zuspruch bekommen hat und viel über diese ganze Pandemie schon berichtet hat.
Er ist halt auch derjenige der sozusagen das offizielle Textbook zum Thema Viren so abgesetzt hat, also er ist sozusagen derjenige, der so das das Fachstandardwerk zum Thema Viren
USA abgeliefert hat und von daher sehr bekannt und überhaupt ein ganz angenehmer Kerl, wenn man ihn so zuschaut und er hat dann als diese
ganze Geschichte aufkam mit dem UK-Warus und äh dieser Behauptung der erhöhten Transmissibilität und äh dann eben auch speziell in Reaktion auf dieses Nerv Tech-Dokument, was sich hier
letzte Mal zitiert habe, hat er sich das mal angeschaut, äh nebst ähm ersten Sequenzierungs äh Analysen, nicht? Also man hat sich halt
Okay, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich bei diesem Virus anders? Und na ja, er hat dann doch.
Sagen wir mal so seine seine virologische Skepsis ein wenig an den Tag gelegt. Zunächst einmal ähm.
Denn diese Schlussfolgerung, dass diese Variante tatsächlich sich schneller verbreitern würde, ja ob die denn sozusagen auch zu halten ist, so aus einer biologischen Perspektive. Und.
Zunächst aber muss man sich mal anschauen, was was macht eigentlich diese Muttertion, ne? Also Mutation gibt's immer, ne? Also es ist sozusagen normale Sache und.
Wie du schon sagst, es kann auch eben davon abhängen, in welchen Host das stattfindet. Also so eine immungeschwächte Person,
Die quasi mit ihrem Körper einen anderen anderen Bedingungen äh bietet, kann tatsächlich eben solche Mutationen.
Beflügeln, so wie wir das auch gesehen haben mit dieser Cluster Five Variante in Dänemark, wo der Virus ja einmal in die Nerze und durch die Nerze durchgegangen ist,
So klassisches ähm klassische Situation mit diesen Nerzen, dass eben Viren dort äh sich einfach anders austoben, weil sie einfach anders oder eben auch gar nicht bekämpft werden.
Jetzt rein virologisch und da setzt natürlich bei mir so mein Grundwissen äh,
auch ein bisschen aus, aber ich habe mich wirklich deihart in der letzten Woche wirklich mit so äh ich habe mir so lange auch Videos von ähm.
In diesem Podcast angeschaut, noch ein paar andere Sachen, bis ich irgendwie so langsam das Gefühl hatte, so jetzt jetzt kann ich in ihrer Sprache auch so halbwegs passen. Äh trotzdem bleibt es schwierig
also zunächst einmal die Mutter ist im Wesentlichen so, dass so ein paar Elemente wurden gelöscht,
Gab also eine sogenannte sogenannte Delitions, so dass so bestimmte Protein
Ausprägungen oder Minosäuren in diesem Protein nicht mehr zu sehen sind. Ein paar haben sich äh äh geändert.
Nur eins.
Hat sich geändert, was auch tatsächlich an diesem Spike-Protein an der Stelle ist, wo das Virus an dieser ACE zwei Rezeptoren andock.
Und so von dem ersten Blick äh aus ist da erstmal überhaupt nicht viel zu sehen.
Jetzt übersetzt aus dieser Perspektive, die er in diesem Video äh geschildert hat, ja? Ich kann das nicht beurteilen,
die jetzt zwingend für nirgendeiner Form dafür sprechen könnte. Es schließt dich aus, aber es ist sozusagen diese er hat sich hier so anfasst etwas ein bisschen eine sehr Schlussfolgerung.
Gestört. Dazu ist es wohl noch so, dass in dem genetischen Kot auch noch so eine hm.
Also da da gehe ich auch nachher nochmal drauf an, so eine Art äh so ein sogenannter Stopcode ist. Das bedeutet einfach, dass bestimmte Proteine dann überhaupt nicht mehr dabei sind oder Teile äh nicht mehr dabei sind. Und ähm.
Dass das sogar darauf hinweisen könnte, dass man eben hier so diesen Klassiker hat mit OKs, Virus kann sich vielleicht besser verbreiten, aber ist unter Umständen auch nicht mehr so pathogen.
Was vielleicht auch ein Grund dafür ist, dass es nicht schneller verbreitet. Also viele, viele Fragezeichen, er hatte so ein bisschen ähm seine Bedenken,
dass er auch eine größeren Runde mit seinen ganzen Kollegen dann in diesem Podcast nochmal diskutiert, habe ich mir gestern irgendwie nochmal eine Stunde angehört,
Wobei sich mittlerweile dann eben auch so die äh Sichtwohl verfestigt durch weitere Studien aus
Britannien, dass da wohl eine Menge dran ist, ne? Und das ist ein ganz interessanter
wie soll ich sagen, intellektuelle Auseinandersetzung hier, weil du hast so auf der einen Seite so diese virologische Perspektive und auf der anderen Seite die Epidemologische Perspektive.
Und ne, während die Virologen halt immer ganz handfesselt etwas biologisch festmachen wollen.
Mechanismus.
Ja, ein Mechanismus, irgendwas, woran man das irgendwie erklären kann, wo man das simulieren kann, wo man's nachvollziehen, wo man's vor allem experimentell nachstellen kann. Während die Epidemiologen hal.
Nicht experimentell unterwegs sind, ist es auch wissenschaft, ja? Bloß die machen keine Experimente, die betrachten sozusagen das Geschehen und versuchen daraus ihre Schlüsse zu ziehen, ne. Ich habe jetzt auch nochmal so ein äh Technical Briefing,
vom vom UKE-Government äh verlinkt, wo das auch nochmal,
was halt auch bei diesem letzten Podcast auch nochmal diskutiert wurde.
Ich sage jetzt mal in der Summe, die die Anzeichen verdichten sich, dass an dieser erhöhten Transmessibilität was dran ist. Aber der Grund dafür, der ist nicht bekannt. Und es kann halt und das ist auch so Teil dieser äh ersten Kritik gewesen.
Einfach auch sehr viel was einfach mit UK zu tun haben
Es kann einfach was, ich meine, wir wir sehen das Ding in London, wir sehen das in Südengland, wir sehen das sozusagen ähm sehr bevölkerungsstarken Raum. Wir reden von einer Gesellschaft, die ihre Schwierigkeiten gehabt hat, ihre Maßnahmen zu beschließen
sehr oft verspätet eingeschlossen hat, die Lokdowns erst sehr spät wirklich äh stark gemacht hat, also Prinzip wie Deutschland nur eben viel schlimmer
Ja und dann ja auch äh eine extreme Überlastung in den Krankenhäusern hatte und so weiter und so weiter und
dass das dann eben sozusagen auch ein Teil der Erklärung ist. Ja, das hier quasi einfach für diese Situation dann auf einmal so ein.
Wie groß daher kam, was einfach diese Gelegenheit genutzt hätte, auch wenn's im Prinzip irgendeine andere Mutter hätte sein können, die diese Gelegenheit genutzt hat. Es war halt dann nur in dem Moment gerade diese, ja? Also das bleibt.
Alles noch so ein bisschen offen. Dazu kommt noch, dass äh eine Sache noch, dass die.
Wir haben ja auch darüber gesprochen, okay, in Großbritannien wird viel sequenziert.
Ja, das ist richtig und jetzt würde hätte man ja fast so erwartet, so ja, die nehmen jetzt so viele Proben, die haben halt überall genau diese Motationen gefunden. Ganz so ist es nicht, sondern.
Die Art dieser Muttertion führt dazu, dass die derzeit durchgeführten PCR-Test, die ja im Prinzip auch nur so eine Art Programm sind, was eben,
bestimmte Dinge äh testet äh und auch verschiedene Stellen quasi auch prüft. Da ist nicht nur so irgendwie.
Null eins Virus da, Virus nicht da, sondern du testest das ja dadurch, dass du eben auf bestimmte Stellen dieses Genoms gegencheckst.
Im Prinzip kann man sagen wie wie
und sagen zwei oder drei verschiedene halt Probs oder Suchstrings könnte man sagen wenn du halt einfach das Virus genomm.
Ähm als String, als Textsequenz darstellst
so es war halt dann ja zwei oder drei Sequenzen, die dann halt gefunden werden müssen in dem, in dem genommen, damit der Test als positiv gilt.
Genau. Angenommen, angenommen, du suchst jetzt nach Kopien von irgendwelchen Klassen äh Arbeiten, ja, die im Netz so rumgeistern
Aber du hast äh äh nicht die Kapazität wirklich äh Wort für Wort, alles zu prüfen, dann guckst du halt nur nach einem bestimmten Suchsdrink, so wie das bei Google halt eigentlich auch machst, da gibt's halt fünf Worte ein und,
äh
Jetzt ist es halt so, dass eben diese Mutation, diese Variante äh dazu geführt hat, dass halt bei diesem PCR-Test, das ist dann im Ergebnis quasi sichtbar, so wie diese PCR-Tasse läuft, das ist so eine Fehlstelle gibt sozusagen. Und daran haben sie dann eben das so umgemap
gesagt, so ja okay, dann muss das aber diese Variante sein, ohne dass jetzt direkt sequenziert zu haben.
Genau das und das,
zu sagen, das ist halt äh wohl dann einer dieser man muss erstmal sagen, dass nicht alle Tests gleich sind, sondern auch vom, also zum einen haben derselbe Hersteller oft verschiedene Tests sogar im im
Angebot mit eben unterschiedlichen Propes und was wohl aber ein verbreiteter Test, der halt,
einen von ein bestimmtes Bike-Protein äh testet, äh dann eben auf diese Mutation nicht.
Anspricht, was dann dazu führt, dass so halt dann eben nur zwei von den drei Markern dann positiv sind, wenn nur einen äh mit,
äh ja jetzt drei Props verwendest, nimmst du halt nur einen mit zwei Props oder einen, der halt,
mich auf das Protein, auf dem Spike gehen, testest, dann äh hast du halt entweder keinen Unterschied oder.
Im anderen Fall, wenn nun halt nur auf zwei Marker teste sind einer davon ist das S Protein, dann würde der Test
halt als Negativ gelten oder wenn das im Labor auffällt, kann sein, dass dann nochmal ein anderer Test gemacht wird oder wenn das gehäuft auftritt, dass man dann halt.
Ähm das nochmal anders testet, aber,
ist auch, dass je nachdem, was für Tests verwendet werden und ich weiß es nicht, welche Tests in deutschen Labors verwendet äh werden, kann es eben auch sein, dass äh dieser Virus von manchen Tests eben nicht erkannt wird
aber da das jetzt bekannt ist, gehe ich davon aus, dass das mittlerweile äh gefixt ist, das Problem ist, also die Labore dafür sensibilisiert sind, dass das passieren kann und das jetzt
im Moment nicht wirklich ein Problem mehr darstellt, hoffe ich.
Nee, das glaube ich auch nicht. Also die können sich daran anpassen. Wie schnell so ein Turnaround ist, weiß ich nicht, äh können wir.
Ich habe, glaube ich, auf so eine Zahl gehört, so aber ich denke mal, so in zwei Wochen lässt sich das äh lässt sich das äh schon wieder einkreisen, weil man weiß halt auf was man was man sucht und dann dann stellt man seine Maschinen seine Tests entsprechend ein.
Ja, also für mich ohne da äh,
jetzt in alle Details reingegangen äh zu sein, bin ich der Meinung, dass tatsächlich.
Dieses Virus äh ansteckender ist. Und zwar aufgrund von ihm vor allem zwei Indizien.
Wobei das Hauptindize ist, dass es sich durchgesetzt hat,
offenbar gegenüber anderen Virusvarianten, wobei Christian Drosten sagt, ja das kann Zufall sein, welche Variante sich durchsetzt, wenn diese Variante gerade eine Ahnung ausgerechnet äh
bei jemandem auftritt, der dann äh zum Supersprayer wird und dann sich deswegen äh durchsetzt, aber.
Dass,
halte ich eher auch in dem Kontext nicht für Zufall in Verbindung mit der Tatsache, dass es eben dreiundzwanzig äh Motationen gibt
insgesamt bei dieser Variante äh die dann doch äh ja einfach
schon bedeutsam sind wahrscheinlich, wenn man so viele Mutationen hat, normalerweise würde man davon ausgehen, weil Mutationen eher,
Normalerweise dem Virus Schaden äh so ähm.
Aber die Tatsache, dass es sich ausgebreitet hat, trotz dieser vielen Montationen ist eigentlich für mich auch eher ein Indiz dafür, äh dass das Virus von diesen Mutationen profitiert.
Und dass das kein Zufall ist.
Ja okay. Aber das ich will, also ich deute mal das, was ich jetzt so alles gehört habe und gelesen habe dazu als.
Kann sein, aber wenn es so ist, weiß man noch nicht genau warum.
Es ist eher eine Feststellung, also es ist noch keine Erklärung und es bedarf äh hier noch weiteren Untersuchungen und auch hm zum Beispiel im Design, den Nerv Tech äh Dokument wurde ja dann auch dieser CT-Wert nochmal.
Gesagt und ich glaube, ich hatte das zu dem Zeitpunkt auch so verstanden und wiedergegeben, so ja okay, CT Wert niedriger, sprich Virus lässt sich schneller entde
mit weniger Durchläufen, weil dieser CT-Wert ist ja sozusagen diese Replikationszeit, also wie oft musst du den Test wiederholen, um auf so ein bestimmtes Minimum zu kommen, umso mehr RNA von vornherein da ist
Ähm umso weniger Durchläufe brauchst du und dass man dann in deiner Form daraus ableiten kann. Ja okay, dann ist da jetzt auch mehr Virus. Das Problem ist nur.
Das funktioniert so nicht. Du hast ähm,
eine sehr hohe Abhängigkeit davon, wie diese Probe entnommen wird und wo die entnommen wird und wie die entnommen wird und deswegen kannst du das äh überhaupt nicht,
generalisieren, also zumindest äh die Virologen haben da äh kräftig den Kopf geschüttelt äh zu dieser Analyse und ich glaube, das ist irgendwie.
Noch ein bisschen offen. Und es ist auch egal. Also es ist äh das haben sie halt auch betont, ne. Erstmal, was kann man jetzt dagegen machen? Muss man überhaupt was gegen machen.
Ja, nie. Also erstmal man hat es jetzt überall gefunden, es ist in USA, es ist in Deutschland, es ist überall, es ist einfach der Gedanke, man könnte jetzt den Tunnel zu machen und irgendwie die Schiffe äh die LKWs äh äh stoppen so ins Over. So, das das
Christoph nicht gebrochen und vor allem es ist eigentlich auch Wurst, weil man weiß jetzt schon, was man dagegen tun kann,
Nämlich das, was man die ganze Zeit schon dagegen getan äh hat, nämlich irgendwie Distanzierung, Masken tragen und so weiter ist die einzige Möglichkeit, da ändert jetzt diese neue Variante auch nix und dass die in irgendeiner Form gefährlicher ist.
Ist überhaupt nicht belegt.
Das ist also da ist sogar so, dass da die Ergebnisse bisher darauf hindeuten sogar, dass sie,
definitiv nicht gefährlicher ist, was jetzt die ja das das Krankmachen angeht. Also diese.
Portuginität.
Ja äh genau die sagen das sagen schwere Fälle, Todesfälle oder Symptome.
Wohl nicht schlimmer sind bei dieser äh neuen Variante was schon mal gut ist.
Ja und vielleicht ist es auch besser. Ich meine, das ist ja eigentlich der normale Lauf der Dinge. Wir entpassen sich halt äh an und äh am Ende kommen so die Sachen bei raus, die halt eine Weitergabe ermöglichen, ungleich alle umzubringen, weil wenn deine Horst umbringst, ist halt auch nicht gut.
Und das das haben wir glaube ich auch von Anfang an schon mal äh hier
gesagt und es kann sein, kann auch nicht sein, kann aber auch sein, dass das hier schon die erste, das erste Zeichen davon ist. Gut.
Ja, ich meine, was wir ja gut gibt jetzt noch zwei, zwei Dinge äh zu der Sache. Äh erstens, man hat mir zwar beim letzten Mal auch schon äh kurz äh erwähnt.
Nehme ich mit dem sagen wie viele jetzt.
Leute in Deutschland bereits mit der UK-Variante rumlaufen könnten oder sie,
bereits gehabt haben, äh könnten und da hatten wir ja gesagt, dass es also,
ja irgendwo zwischen hundert und dreihundert pro Tag sein könnten, ohne dass es bisher aufgefallen ist. Es gab jetzt ein paar Entdeckungen.
So gut die Zahlen sind noch zu niedrig, aber man kann sagen, dass es,
äh mittlerweile in Deutschland äh auch wahrscheinlich so weit verbreitet ist, dass hier es nicht mehr äh gestoppt kriegen. So und wie du schon richtig sagt, das.
Dass die normalen Maßnahmen wirken auch bei diesem Virus äh oder bei dieser Virusvariante.
Aber wenn sich jetzt die,
höhere Übertragbarkeit, äh was mit einem äh höheren,
Reproduktionspferd mit einem höheren R null auch einhergeht. Äh wenn sich das bestätigt dann ähm führt das aber dazu.
Das wurde noch wenig thematisiert, dass äh wir äh erst,
später eine Herdenimmunität für diese Variante kriegen, weil eine ungefähre Annäherung, wie viel Prozent der Bevölkerung,
jetzt immun sein müssen, damit der sagen, RT oder eine effektive RWT unter eins äh sinkt, ähm.
Braucht man, ich sag mal, bei Corona Classic, wenn man jetzt von einem R null von zwei Komma fünf ausgeht, kommt man auf ungefähr sechzig Prozent der Bevölkerung, die immun sein müssen, bis das Virus,
nicht mehr genug Leute findet ähm beziehungsweise bis eben RT,
dadurch, dass so viele Leute Immun sind, auch ohne weitere Maßnahmen sich totläuft, so kann man vielleicht das mit der Herden äh Immunität,
sehen, so das kann dann zwar auch noch lange dauern. Wenn du aber jetzt sagst, wenn jetzt Corona neu jetzt einen R null von vier hätte, was immer noch
weniger ist als das, was jetzt in diesem Nervtag Paper und so ähm
angegeben ist, dann müssten's mindestens fünfundsiebzig Prozent der Bevölkerung sein, um es sogar achtzig Prozent, die,
ja Immun sein müssen bevor sich,
ohne zusätzliche Maßnahmen der Virus tot läuft und das wäre, wenn sich das bestätigt natürlich Auswirkungen auch auf das gesamte Impfthema.
Das heißt
ja, dass wir einfach eine größere Zahl durchimpfen müssen und dass auch dann gegenüber der neuen Variante sich eine Verlangsamung erst später einstellt
aufgrund ja von Impfungen, dass es halt ja sich,
Impfungen eben auf die neue Virusvariante dann Epidemiologisch erst später auswirken.
Und äh ja bei denen wiederum Betrachtungen, wie viele Leute sich impfen oder nicht impfen lassen wollen, ist das natürlich schon ein signifikanter.
Wobei ich sagen mussten auch wenn eine Impfung da ist und wenn ich geimpft bin ähm.
Ja wäre mir das eigentlich dann auch fast egal, ob sich dann andere Leute impfen lassen oder nicht.
Allerdings nur fast egal, weil ja ähm es halt dann trotzdem noch unschuldige.
Trifft, weil eben ähm ja, trotzdem dann mehr Leute erkranken und ja, also,
Willst das nicht haben, dass dass
Dann natürlich auch die Gefahr weiterer Mutationen auch besteht, wie das Ganze läuft dann länger die gesamte Infektion und es kann dann sein, wenn wenn man's, wenn man's halt nicht schnell tot kriegen, dass wir dann irgendwann Varianten kriegen.
Die richtig unangenehm sind und wo wir dann.
Ja mit dem Impfen dann vielleicht nicht hinterherkommen oder wo der Impfstoff nicht mehr wirkt, wo wir dann plötzlich einfach die gesamte Bevölkerung nochmal neu durchimpfen müssen und so insofern
ja, ich der Meinung, also es so schnell wie möglich, so stark wie möglich reduzieren und so viel wie möglich impfen, sonst,
geht das nicht gut aus am Ende.
Gut, kommen wir mal auf äh,
ein anderes Thema und zwar ist mir hier noch ein Artikel über eine Studie über den Weg gelaufen, der na ja ein bisschen nachdenklich macht
Nämlich äh eine Studie von, glaube ich, amerikanischen Wissenschaftlern an Kindern in Südkorea und ähm die meinen halt belegen zu können oder zumindest festgestellt zu haben
dass bei Kindern durchaus höhere Infektions.
Zeiträume vorzufinden sind und äh auch bei kleinen Kindern sehr hohe Viruslast.
Diese Diskussion gibt's ja schon lange, da gab's ja dieses äh Drostenpapier und die ganze Debatte äh da droben nicht. Niemand wusste eigentlich so ganz genau, okay, sind jetzt Kinder irgendwie nicht betroffen, weil sie sich gar nicht erst infizieren
oder sind sie eben nur nicht so betroffen, weil sie nicht krank werden. Ich denke, es zeichnet sich mittlerweile ab.
Mindestens das Kinderhalt genauso ansteckend sind und genauso davon betroffen sind, nur eben ihr,
noch ungeprägtes Immunsystem in der Lage ist, damit eben sehr viel besser umzugehen als eben ältere Semester,
deren Immunsystem eben verschiedene Dinge schon mal hier so ein bisschen gesehen hatten, da schon mal ein bisschen gesehen hatten, von daher eben nicht in der Lage ist, gegen Saas Koff zwei den vollen Apparat einzusetzen und dementsprechend dann,
im Kampf gegen den Virus auch unterliegen kann,
Ja so und das ist natürlich ja, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, beunruhigende Nachrichten. Wir haben hier so viele unberuhigende Nachrichten, vor allem haben wir oft so
so Meldungen, wo man dann später feststellt, so, ja okay, gut, das war jetzt die Studie, jetzt kommt da wieder eine andere Studie, die die relativiert das wieder und ich will das hier überhaupt gar nicht
dass das jetzt äh da in einer Richtung weist, aber das wirft natürlich so ein bisschen die,
eigentliche Frage auch auf, nämlich was ist denn nun die Rolle der Schulen, wenn man jetzt sozusagen an die
eine potenzielle Beendigung äh der Lokdownmaßnahmen in Deutschland diskutieren, werden wir natürlich jetzt gerade in der nächsten Woche wieder viel zum Thema.
Schulen hören, da half es dann auch nicht, dass äh erst fragt den Staat ein Projekt, was immer ganz fleißig dabei ist, über die den Mechanismus der Informationsfreiheitsanfrage.
Informationen dem Staat zu entrücken.
Das äh fragt den Staat, ähm rausgeklagt hat eine Sequenzierungsanalyse eines Corona-Ausbruchs an einer Hamburger Schule.
Dass die den äh bekommen haben und dann veröffentlicht haben, aus dem dann tatsächlich hervorging, dass offensichtlich so ein Supersprayer-Event war, also dass.
Das als es da öffentlich bis dahin immer dargestellt wurde, nicht so ein diffuses Infektionsgeschehen ist, was von außen reingetragen wurde, sondern dass es eben tatsächlich so einen Supersprayer gab
das konnte man dann eben durch die Sequenzierung äh sehen, nicht weil das hatten wir ja hier schon einige Male, man schaut sich halt ganz genau das äh RNA genommen
der Viren, die dort eben bei den Leuten bei Tests gefunden wurden und dann kann man eben anhand der Ähnlichkeit schon sehen, wer da wem, was wie gegeben hat, das sind halt ein Aufwand, den ich immer getrieben werden äh kann und schon gar nicht immer getrieben wird.
Aber hier war das dann eben so klar, dass äh hier offensichtlich eine Person in der Schule halt mal eben vierzig andere äh ja infiziert hat.
Untersuchung vom Heinrich Petter Institut und Uniklinikum in Eppendorf.
Und meinten halt so, nee, hier fast alles identische DNA. Das ist schon sehr wahrscheinlich, dass es alles durch eine einzige Person äh ausgelöst wurde und.
Finde ich halt immer sehr problematisch, ne? Also wenn solche Informationen vorliegen und nicht veröffentlicht werden, das hilft einfach in der ganzen öffentlichen Debatte nicht, ne? Und das ist,
jetzt wirklich die Frage, wie gehen wir damit jetzt um und was sollte sozusagen die Forderung sein? Mal aus einer ganz persönlichen Perspektive,
rein theoretisch hätte ja die Schule am zehnten Januar beginnen sollen. Ich glaub der Beschluss zumindest in Berlin das jetzt mal mindestens eine Woche zu verschieben, der ist schon da.
Ähm nur irgendwann irgendwann werden sie halt wieder anfangen, die Schulen zu öffnen.
Und finde ich auch so ein bisschen fies. So, ich meine, da sitzt man dann so zu Hause. Carantinisiert sich so vor sich hin.
Tut irgendwie alles, was man äh tun kann und dann wird dann dieses Tor geöffnet und da hast du gar keine Chance, ne?
Genau Androhung von Geld und Gefängnisstrafen dazu gezwungen äh seine äh Kinder äh jeden Tag äh in einem potenziellen Infektionsherd
zu
schicken und äh ja kann eigentlich wenig dagegen tun. Das ist ja nicht nicht in Ordnung und
Gut, diese eine Studie oder dieser dieser eine Fall ähm heißt jetzt erstmal nur okay.
Es kann trotzdem zu Superstrading kommen und nicht notwendigerweise Schulen sind jetzt überall sagen Orte von äh superspreading
So, also wie viele Leute neigen denn ja immer äh dazu, dass äh echt allzu sehr zu verallgemeinern. Aber,
was man definitiv sagen kann, umgekehrt, Schulen sind nicht,
sicher, ja. So, das äh kann man erstmal ähm aufgrund äh auch dieser dieser dieser einzelnen äh Sache,
dann feststellen und wann, wann waren das der Ausbruch? Äh, weißt du das?
Zeitraum. Ja und,
auch noch sogar zu einer Zeit wo wir zumindest gegenüber jetzt eine deutlich bessere Situation hatten, was so Institzen äh angeht und äh anderen Worten.
Aktuell sind die Gefahren äh eben sogar noch größer, würde ich sagen. Äh wobei, ja, das sicherlich auch
davon abhängt, welche Maßnahmen da in den Schulen vorgenommen werden und ich kann mir durchaus auch vorstellen, dass es Schulen gibt, wo das so gut funktioniert, äh dass es tatsächlich.
Relativ sicher ist, aber ich bin mir auch ziemlich sicher, dass es einen Haufen Schulen wahrscheinlich sogar die Mehrzahl der Schulen gibt, wo es einfach genau.
Würde ich sagen gar nicht, aber wo es einfach desaströs funktioniert. Ich meine, ist auch wenn man einfach nur.
Normal sieht, was an Schulen so schief läuft,
äh an Unterrichtsausfällen sind normalen Zeiten sind Schulen jetzt nicht so die Orte, die jetzt alle so perfekt gemanagt sind, sondern wir haben ja jede Menge Problemschulen auch äh einfach und ja.
Und man weiß natürlich.
Nicht wirklich, ähm wie gut das oder wie sicher die Kinder einfach in der, in der Schule sind, da gibt's genau null Garantien,
für und ja, ich weiß nicht, was ist dein Eindruck von den von den Schulen, äh, wo deine Kinder äh sind, wie.
Ja ist ein bisschen schwierig da so aus der Ferne zu beurteilen. Es gab halt jetzt beim großen Satz in dem Gymnasium erstmal.
Tragen dort die Kids alle Maske auch im Unterricht. Das finde ich schon mal gut, so. Das ist eine Grundschule.
Dann glaub ich nicht so. Ähm und das hat auch schon geholfen, es gab auch den Fall einer Lehrerin, die,
sich infiziert hatte und die auch Unterricht gegeben hatte, aber die im Unterricht halt auch immer selber Maske getragen hat, während des Unterrichts
und da ist auch nichts bekannt, dass da in irgendeiner Form was passiert ist. Also es ist nicht so, dass man dort nichts verhindern könnte.
Es müsste halt nur konsequent auch durchgesetzt werden und ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt bisher noch von keiner hab ich noch keine Ansage gehört, wo generell Maskenpflicht im Unterricht herrschen würde. Das wäre aber wahrscheinlich eine gute Idee.
Ich weiß es nicht, nicht einfach und so weiter gerade auch so als Lehrerin, Lehrer äh verstanden zu werden, also rein akustisch verstanden zu werden mit Masken ist alles schwieriger.
Aber was ist halt die Alternative? Na gut, müssen wir jetzt auch nicht weiter drauf rum äh hacken. Ich denke mal, das werden wir dann auch in der nächsten Woche, wenn wir am achten Juni zusammenkommen, da wird's dann diese Taroung gegeben haben wieder, der.
Ministerpräsidentin oder der äh ich weiß nicht ganz genau, ob das diese Kultusministerkonferenz ist, also auf jeden Fall wird's Entscheidungen dazu geben zum Doktor und natürlich dann auch zu den Schulen. Dann können wir das ja auch nochmal aufgreifen.
Ja. Ja, es gab, weil es gab ja auch schon von Gesundheitsministerin oder oder Bildungsministerin, die gesagt hat, wir machen auf, egal wie die Zahlen aussehen, wenn du das mitgekriegt hast.
Naja, ich nicht mitbekomme, aber sowas will ich auch nicht.
Nee, das äh ja, das fand ich, ging einfach gar nicht.
Man muss ja zwei Sachen auch mal unterscheiden. Die Schule hat zu, er ist in Urlaub wird verlängert, mit es findet kein Unterricht statt, ja? Versus.
Der Unterricht findet statt, aber unter geänderten Bedingungen, so und mit entsprechenden Schutzmaßnahmen. Und da gibt's halt
das Minimum an Schutzmaßnahmen ist halt natürlich klar, hier Aha-Regeln, Tralala, Maske, äh im Unterricht im Idealfall. Das ist das eine,
Aber das andere ist natürlich, dass man auch möglichst alles dafür tun sollte, um diese Präsenz nicht unbedingt so notwendig werden zu lassen
und es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es noch keiner Schule gelungen wäre eben so ein aufgeteilten Unterricht zu machen. Entweder halt.
Was aber dann so ein bisschen doof ist mit Aufteilung und dann hat immer nur die eine von den beiden Unterricht oder eben einfach zu sagen, na ja, wir machen jetzt hier irgendwie.
Mit Webcam und Livestreaming und Pipapo und der Unterricht findet auch statt, dann sind die Kids halt zu Hause und schauen sich das halt Remote an und.
Ich weiß, dass es ein höherer Aufwand, aber jetzt.
Dass du wirklich auch schon fast ein Jahr das Thema. Also es ist solche Lösungen müssen auch gefunden werden können. Ich bin ja schon froh, dass jetzt überhaupt so eine gewisse Cloud-Infrastruktur am Start ist, ja? Also da ein.
Meines Sohnes, da ist dann halt auch hier so HPI Schulcloud und so weiter am Start, die hatten am Anfang dann auch erstmal so ihre Zusatzprobleme und waren langsam und es dauert und so und sicherlich ist da auch nicht alles perfekt.
Verdammt nochmal, es gibt zumindest mal ein System, wo so die Hausaufgaben drinstehen und was gelernt werden soll und ich meine, das wäre auch mal so ein ganz selbst ohne Pandemie wäre das hilfreich.
Das ist einfach da braucht's jetzt einfach nicht so eine apokalyptische Situation, um einzusehen, dass es dann doch vielleicht mal ganz cool wäre, wenn so der Unterricht so zumindest digital begleitet wird. Ich meine, es gibt immer Kinder, die krank sind,
Es ist einfach,
Man ist halt manchmal einfach mal krank und wenn ein Kind zwei Wochen fehlt und nicht zur Schule gehen kann, ist es raus. So und dann bist du doppelt bestraft. Erstens warst du krank. Und dann musst du irgendwie auch noch alles doppelt lernen und so und es gibt einfach viele Krankheiten. Ja okay, dann,
gerade wenn da halt Infektionskrankheit hast, darfst halt nicht in die Schule, aber du kannst auch trotzdem lernen, wenn du alleine bist und solche Systeme,
erlauben das halt oder machen es zumindest möglich dem in irgendeiner Form zu folgen. Stattdessen gibt's dann immer so Telefon,
und irgendwie
geteilte Schüler, wo man dann anrufen soll und mal fragen soll und kopier mir doch mal das und mach mal ein Foto von Seite fünfzehn und das das kann's einfach nicht sein, wenn einfach diese ganzen Lehrmittel und auch,
ganzen Bücher im Prinzip ja eigentlich auch alle im Netz vorrätig sein können
Ja, also es ist eine lange Diskussion und ehrlich gesagt, ich will jetzt an dieser Stelle auch gar nicht weiter führen, weil das Schule ist immer nochmal so ein Fass ohne Boden,
Sache ist, um's zusammenzufassen. Es gibt durchaus Erkenntnisse, dass eben die Kinder auch nochmal überdurchschnittlich äh ansteckend sein können. Ja, kann sein, auch dass es.
Nicht stimmt, aber so ist gerade mal wieder eine weitere Erkenntnislage gewesen und äh so ne Geschichten wie hier mit dieser äh ja Nichtveröffentlichung von Superspredder Events, das macht nicht unbedingt gerade,
viel Vertrauen und Vertrauen brauchen wir an dieser Stelle.
So dann noch eine Kleinigkeit. Ähm ich hatte da glaube ich auch schon mal hier von berichtet vor einiger Zeit, auch weil ich das selber benutzt habe, als ich hier noch äh unterwegs war und,
meine Interviews gemacht habe in Deutschland. Dass man nämlich äh auf Amazon sich so ein Testkit kaufen konnte.
Von der Firma Cento Jean, die ja auch viele dieser Flughafen ähm im FZ fast gesagt, Testzentren unterhalten.
Ähm da kriegst du so eine kleine Box und da ist da so ein Stückchen drin und ein Assortment von Plastiktüten und Röhrchen und dann kannst du da halt selber einen Abstrich machen, steckst den in so ein,
Röhrchen rein, machst das alles zu und ja folgst den Instruktionen, um daraus so ein abholfertiges Paket zu machen, dann kommt
äh dann sagst du halt online, so ja, hier Abstrich gemacht, schick mal Kurier vorbei, dann kommt dir ein Tag später, sammelt sich das Tütchen ein, dann geht es über Nacht,
zum Testzentrum und da hat man in der Regel auch bald sein Ergebnis.
Gibt's nicht mehr, ist nicht mehr kaufbar, weil äh hier wohl wettbewerbsrechtliche Gründe.
Vorlagen, um das äh zu unterbinden, ja.
Das heißt man kann jetzt sozusagen diese schöne Variante nicht mehr benutzen.
Weil das irgendwelchen Wettbewerbsrechtlichen Gründen widerspricht. Ja, also es verstößt angeblich hier.
Weil mhm.
Wie ist die Variante äh Paragraph zwölf des Heilmittel-Werbegesetzes, wonach unter anderem nicht für Medizinprodukte geworben werden darf, die der Erkennung meldepflichtiger Erkrankung nach Infektionsschutzgesetz dienen.
Mhm. Okay. Warum gibt's das? Was.
Warum? Also ich verstehe überhaupt gar nicht was was jetzt hier eigentlich verhindert werden soll.
Ja, ich meine, damit fällt sozusagen so eine Methode weg, mit der man.
Zumindest und gewisse äh Abdeckung von Test bekommen kann. Ich meine, ich habe noch ein paar von den Dingern bei mir rumliegen, weil ich die halt einfach mal so im Fünferpack gekauft habe, so liegen jetzt rum. Derzeit gibt's relativ wenig anders
nicht wahr, aber wenn jetzt wieder äh irgendeine Öffnung wieder möglich wäre und ich mich mal wieder raustraue in die Welt, dann äh wäre das halt auf jeden Fall auch eine Methode, um sicherzustellen. So, okay, also
Aber es heißt sicherzustellen, um die Wahrscheinlichkeit zu senken, dass ich äh
mich irgendwie infiziert habe auf irgendeinem Wege. Ne und das gegebenenfalls auch anderen Leuten gegenüber dann halt äh.
Stärker vertreten kann, von Beweisen möchte ich jetzt hier nicht sprechen. Ah, ich finde das ein bisschen,
merkwürdig. Darüber hinaus verstoße die Abgabe des Test Kids gegen Paragraph drei der Medizinprodukteabgabeverordnung,
wonach auch In-vitro-Diagnostica auf CoWIT neunzehn nur ein Fachhändler und medizinische Fachkreise abgegeben werden dürften,
Na ja, also da ist jetzt wird gerade irgendwie geklagt, es hat ja auch viele Monate gedauert, bis sie das irgendwie mal bemerkt haben, dass es angeblich dagegen ähm spricht. Derzeit ist es auf jeden Fall nicht zu kaufen und von daher.
Unklar wie das ausgeht.
Ja. Gut, wenn man sagen Sentojin sieht, äh, sieht das halt natürlich anders äh,
so muss man auch sagen äh sagen, es ist lediglich ein Kit zur Gewinnung eines Rachenabstrichs und kein Diagnostikum äh zur Selbstanwendung
was man irgendwie auch nachvollziehen
kann, so und der Test erfolgt ja weiterhin ist es ein normaler PCR-Test, der im Labor durchgeführt wird und der dann auch der Meldepflicht äh unterliegt und so. Insofern, also ich kann mir
vorstellen, dass man natürlich verhindern will, äh dass.
Oder vermute mal der Sinn und Zweck eigentlich dieser Regelung ist, dass nicht irgendwelche Leute jetzt äh selber Tests äh machen im Geheimen und dann Meldepflichtige,
Ergebnisse verschweigen. Ich nehme mal an, dass das ein bisschen dahinter steckt, dass sie halt auch wollen, dass die Meldepflicht durchgesetzt wird, aber das ist ja in dem Fall gegeben.
Ansonsten alles andere ja gut klar äh es besteht dann immer noch die Gefahr, dass äh einfach der
Strich nicht ordnungsgemäß durchgeführt wird ähm wenn Leute das zu Hause machen, aber es gibt ja auch keine wirklichen Konsequenzen eines negativen Tests,
ist ja nicht so, dass du dann mit dem negativen,
oder so, dass dass man sich darauf dann insoweit verlassen sollte, dass man dann keine anderen Schutzmaßnahmen trifft. Das ist halt mehr so ein,
zusätzliches Ding,
Und wenn der Test positiv ist, ist er positiv. So, ja, dann ja, also all all die Folgen, die dann daraus äh äh kommen, ja eher
eher vorteilhaft, dass man nämlich eine Infektion erkannt hat, insofern ja.
Ähm habe ich das Gefühl äh ist das ja,
im Wege stehende Bürokratie in diesem konkreten Fall. Erinnert mich auch äh an das Ding gar nicht, wenn man ganz kurz sieht.
Sache, mit den Dosierungen oder kommen wir da später noch drauf.
Die Dosierung von was.
Vom Impfstoff äh so äh dass äh jetzt festgestellt hat, dass halt in den einzelnen,
Packungen äh in den einzelnen Fläschchen mehr drin ist, als die Ärzte da rausnehmen dürfen. Das ist eigentlich sie nur fünf
Leute mit dem Inhalt einer Flasche spritzen dürfen während wenn man halt das ordentlich aufzieht und,
ja, dass das gut kann, kann man wohl also rein rechnerisch kann man sieben statt fünf.
Portionen da rausholen äh und hat dann immer noch ein bisschen was übrig, theoretisch. So und das geht aber nicht, es muss im Moment so lange äh da jetzt nicht.
Eine Änderung der Zulassung erfolgt müssen so pro.
Fläschchen jetzt ein bis zwei Dosen weggekippt werden im Moment ein Impfstoff. Was natürlich,
auch gerade ein bisschen ungünstig ist, äh wo der Impfstoff nicht so knapp ist. Und das sind halt dann Dinge, ja, wo,
wir uns im Moment selber im Weg rumstehen.
Genau, damit kommen wir im Prinzip schon auch zu dem Thema, äh nämlich Impfungen in Deutschland und wie läuft's denn so mit unseren geilen Impfungen? Und man kann, glaube ich, festhalten, könnt besser laufen.
Ja, es läuft ziemlich holprig
an, so was man äh so hört. Aber es wird natürlich auch viel äh skandalisiert, äh aber es gibt natürlich auch viele kleine Anlässe äh so ähm ja, was ist dir denn da so unter.
Gekommen an Meldungen, abgesehen davon, dass ja offensichtlich Impfstoffe nicht in der Menge angeliefert werden, wie das erwartet oder versprochen war.
Ja, also sagen wir mal so, das jetzt Dinge nicht rundlaufen und so,
geschenkt so, ja? Also das denke ich mal, kann man von vorne rein einpreisen, was ich äh dann aber schon so ein bisschen äh obskur fand, war dann eben die Ankündigung des Bundes. Na ja, man könnte jetzt irgendwie diese ähm.
Angeplante Impfstoffmenge, zumindest nach Berlin nicht ausliefern und es gäbe dann eine Woche lang gar keinen Impfstoff.
Woraufhin sich natürlich die Gesundheitsministerin Berlin äh äh kräftig aufgeregt hat und nach ein paar Diskussionen gab's dann doch wieder was.
Ja, so aus dem Nichts heraus, also gab's jetzt keinen oder sollte der nun nicht,
nach Berlin gehen oder hat man das jetzt irgendwie anders aufgeteilt? Und wieso gab's eigentlich keinen? Also was der Grund dafür, also so ein bisschen unklare Nachrichtenlage, deswegen möchte ich da jetzt auch noch nicht so drüber urteilen. Tatsache ist.
Es ist halt noch nicht richtig losgelaufen.
Man kann ähm die Impfzentren in Berlin können glaube ich in ihrem, also sind Design für bis zu fünftausend Impfungen pro Tag pro Impfzentrum.
Das ist so das, was die irgendwie raushauen können. Setzt natürlich voraus, dass man eben auch die entsprechenden Mengen hat an dem Stoff.
Ja, aber im Moment sind die, glaube ich, alle geschlossen, die Impfzentren in Berlin. Da passiert gar nix, glaube ich im Moment.
Weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau, also es sind halt ein paar Leute schon geimpft worden, teilweise sind dann aber auch die Leute nicht gekommen. Also in den ersten Tagen war es ja auch so, dass man dann eben die Kapazitäten erstmal für die Pflegekräfte freigehalten hat.
Die in Altenheimen arbeiten oder an.
Die nicht freigekriegt haben. Mhm.
Die dann nicht frei bekommen haben. Also es gab ja da zwei Diskussionsebene. Erstmal gab's so diese ganze Diskussion um viele wollen sich nicht impfen lassen aus.
Gründen und andere wollten sich vielleicht impfen lassen, aber haben nicht frei bekommen, weil über die Weihnachtsfeiertage das Personal sowieso so knapp ist.
So, da freue ich mich natürlich jetzt, also wenn das Personal über Weihnachten knapp ist, aber sonst nicht. Wo ist denn das Personal, was fehlt eigentlich dann.
Also ich meine, wenn das Personal knapp ist und die nicht arbeiten, können die sich dann nicht impfen lassen.
Die irgendwie weg oder was? Also das habe ich erstmal nicht begriffen und dann dachte ich mir auch so ähm okay, die kriegen nicht frei.
Wie viel Stunden arbeiten die denn am Tag vierundzwanzig Stunden? Oder arbeiten die acht Stunden oder zehn Stunden.
Was mit den anderen Stunden am Tag? Da hat er wahrscheinlich das Impfzentrum zu. Das heißt, das Impfzentrum macht dann nur von.
Bis achtzehn Uhr dreißig, wie das so in Deutschland so ist, Ladenschussgesetz, Impfzentrums Schlussgesetz.
Und dann machen die zu, weil ist so.
Aha. Also man kann also abends nicht geimpft werden, genauso wie man früher in Deutschland abends nicht im Supermarkt einkaufen konnte.
Ja, aber ich ich verstehe auch die Debatte mit irgendwie wollen nicht geimpft äh äh werden es mir äh völlig.
Aber lass, lass mal das, lass mal das mal raus. So, rein logistisch, gehen wir mal davon aus, äh also ich meine, dass es genug Leute gibt, die derzeit geimpft werden wollen, die man impfen könnte. Das steht, glaube ich, vollkommen außer Frage.
So jetzt hat man sich natürlich gesagt, okay, wir konzentrieren uns jetzt erstmal auf das Personal, also auf diese erste Kohorte, das sind die neunzig Plus und so. Das heißt, hier haben im Wesentlichen finden viele Impfungen, vor allem jetzt von mobilen Einheiten statt. Die sind als in irgendwelche,
Altenheime rein und haben dann irgendwelche äh äh Patienten dort
geimpft und davon, soweit ich das gehört habe, haben sich die meisten halt auch impfen lassen. Beim Personal saß dann schon teilweise anders aus und dann gab's sehr viel Durcheinander mit irgendwie ja, nur zwanzig Prozent wollten sich impfen lassen,
Wo war ich da so mit so ein bisschen Salz nehme, weil.
In der Darstellung ist immer ein bisschen schwierig war. Also teilweise ist dem nachgegangen worden, da gab's einen schönen Artikel bei den Übermedien, wo sie dieser äh DPA-Meldung nochmal nachgegangen sind und ja tatsächlich gab's dann halt ein Altenheim. Ich glaube, es war sogar in Sachsen oder Sachsen-Anhalt,
wo einfach nur zwanzig Prozent des Personals sich impfen lassen wollte,
Hatte das dann moniert und auf Twitter meldeten sich halt ein paar so, ja und muss ja auch verstehen und man ist sicher dann noch unsicher und ob dann das so sicher ist und so.
Gut, aber da ist, also normalerweise, ich kenne das nur so von Freunden, Freundinnen, die halt in Krankenhäusern arbeiten, Krankenschwester oder so. Äh die werden.
Praktisch jedes Jahr gegen irgendwas,
geimpft, ja? Da ist es völlig normal, dass man einfach zusieht, wenn man an einer Stelle arbeitet, wo man mit.
Vielen kranken Leuten,
zusammenkommt, dass du einfach einen Impfstatus hast, ähnlich wie jetzt Soldaten im Auslandseinsatz oder so die bestimmte Gegenden fahren, das so einfach mal äh dagegen
Dutzende von verschiedenen Infektionskrankheiten dich.
Geimpft wirst und deinen Impfstatus aufrecht äh erhältst und jedes Jahr gegen Grippe geimpft wirst, so deswegen dachte ich mir irgendwie äh wie geht denn das jetzt zusammen? Das
achtzig Prozent sich nicht impfen lassen, weil wo das eigentlich äh soweit ich weiß, komplett Standard ist für zumindest Mitarbeiter im Gesundheitswesen,
Was jetzt Altenbetreuung angeht, äh ja.
Und hat mir aber beim letzten Mal auch da gibt's halt eine Menge auch einfach an Hilfskräften, die dort arbeiten,
die.
Ja keinerlei Ausbildung äh haben, ungelernte Hilfskräfte oder so eine wirklich große Zahl und es ist halt eben bekannt, Job im Altenheim,
wenn du halt irgendwie wirklich Arbeit brauchst und dazu in der Lage bist, dann ist das immer eine sichere Bank, da kriegst du also als Altenpfleger kriegst du immer und.
Jeder Stadt irgendwie einen Job, äh, wenn du willst, so und dementsprechend ist aber eben auch ein Teil der der Leute, ja äh.
Sind jetzt nicht, das sind jetzt keine Ärzte oder Krankenschwestern oder Leute, die das jetzt wirklich beruflich machen, sondern oft machen die das halt für Monate oder andere
machen das dann auch vielleicht über Jahrzehnte gut, die sind dann erfahren, aber,
Das ist jetzt nicht so die Situation, dass man sagen kann, okay, das sind jetzt alles irgendwie qualifizierte.
Mitarbeiter des Gesundheitswesens, die jetzt in äh Heimen arbeiten und.
Wenn dazu kommt dann auch noch bisschen auch technisches Personal, als Leute, die vielleicht kochen oder putzen oder äh was auch immer dort dort machen, die eher auch potenziell äh.
Ja, Leute anstecken können dort und ja,
aber ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass dass diese Meldungen da nicht wirklich widerspiegeln, was sich äh so normalerweise abspielt in Krankenhäusern oder,
auch in in Heim. Ich denke mal, dass das Ausnahmen sind.
Es flogen wirklich verschiedenste Sachen äh drumherum und ich gehe auch gleich nochmal auf so ein paar äh allgemeine Argumente äh ein. Auch so dieses so ja, man will sie nicht impfen lassen, weil sie Angst haben, dass wer jetzt geimpft ist, der wird dann irgendwie nur noch auf den Corona-Stationen eingesetzt und haben sie keinen Bock drauf
Also okay, vielleicht haben Leute solche Ängste ja immer nur zu sagen so, ey ihr werdet alle geimpft, also.
Jetzt ist äh wollt ihr und überhaupt mal so ganz davon abgesehen so,
impfen, könnt ihr euch vor Krankheit schützen, so ist das nicht vielleicht auch ein Argument so, bevor ihr irgendwie eure Einteilung nachdenkt am am Job so, dem Zeitfall halt auch noch kündigen kann. Also,
Gut, das will mich da jetzt nicht äh in die einzelnen Motivationen versuchen zu tief reinzudenken.
Sagen, das Ganze vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz logistisch anzuschauen, weil da hilft vielleicht der Blick äh auf die aktuelle Erfolgsstory, nämlich die Impfungs äh Kampagne in Israel. Denn dort geht's richtig zur Sache.
Stand heute aktuelle Zahl sind in Israel bereits elf Komma fünf fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung geimpft.
Ja, ich weiß, kleineres Land, fünf Millionen und so weiter, trotzdem impfen die halt locker viermal so viele Leute pro Tag wie Deutschland und.
Vor allem tun sie das sehr viel kreativer, habe ich so den Eindruck, also ich bin mir nicht so sicher, was so an kulturellen Faktoren da jetzt noch mit reinspielt oder inwiefern die jetzt unter ihren Lokdowns nochmal besonders gelitten haben. Es gab ja da auch enorme Infektionsphasen
auch wenn, glaube ich, unsere jetzt auch gerade nicht so sehr viel anders ist. Die machen Impfungen auf auf Parkplätzen, so Drive-in-mäßig.
Ja, da sitzt man dann irgendwie im Auto, bleibt drin, so am Steuer, wird direkt so geimpft.
Da muss man ja nochmal fünfzehn Minuten beobachtet werden, ne, falls irgendwie sofort Probleme gibt oder stellen die sich dann aber einfach mit der mit dem Gesicht nach vorne äh mit dem Auto dahin.
Wenn die ein Problem haben, ist die Ansage Lichthube machen. Ganz einfach, so und für eine Viertelstunde rum ist, fahren die halt einfach los.
Abmachen und so weiter, dass da keine Komplikationen gibt. Sowas kann man machen. Und vor allem, wenn ich's richtig sehe, ich weiß nicht, ob das für alle Stationen gilt, aber es wird eben auch so vierundzwanzig sieben geimpft.
Wird halt auch Nachladenschluss quasi geimpft. So und wenn halt jemand arbeiten muss dann kann man halt auch um zweiundzwanzig Uhr
Dreiundzwanzig Uhr oder drei Uhr nachts dahingehen und sich impfen lassen und sie schaffen's halt einfach in Windeseile äh hier diesen Impfstoff zu verteilen und es sieht halt derzeit danach aus, dass sie so,
Ende März auf jeden Fall ihre Herden, Immunität erreicht haben.
Und bei uns sieht es halt nicht im Ansatz danach aus. Bei uns sieht's eher so aus, dass so Leute wie wir, so in den Fünfzigern.
Rätseln können, ob's jetzt Mai, Juni oder vielleicht dann doch auch erst Juli wird oder so.
Ja. Oder August.
Ja so, also was ja jetzt so nicht ganz unerheblich ist für die Jahresplanung. Ich.
Ja, also ich hoffe, ich hoffe, dass das Problem wird sich lösen. Äh ein Faktor ist natürlich, wir haben zu wenig Impfstoff bestellt bei.
Björn Tech, der nach wie vor der einzige zugelassene Impfstoff ist, also jetzt in den nächsten Tagen wird der moderne RNA-Impfstoff auch noch mit dazu kommen. Das wird vielleicht etwas Entlastung bringen, aber grundsätzlich sieht es wohl derzeit so aus, dass die Nachfrage groß ist,
der Chef von ähm Björn Tech, der Shaine, der hat sicher auch dazu geäußert und meint so, ja, er hat jetzt die Einkaufspolitik der EU auch nicht so richtig gecheckt, die hätten also durchaus da noch,
mehr zuschlagen können und er versteht ja auch, dass die da versucht haben, auf verschiedene Pferde zu setzen und das nicht unbedingt jetzt von vornherein so,
ersichtlich war, was denn jetzt hier das Rennen quasi gewinnen wird,
Nichtsdestotrotz hätte es wohl mehrere Gelegenheiten gegeben, größere Mengen noch äh sicherzustellen und dem sei nicht nachgegangen worden. Auf EU-Ebene muss man dazu sagen. Und jetzt hätte man so ein bisschen den Salat, dass sie halt nicht die Mengen kriegen,
davon abgesehen, diese Forderung, dass jetzt immer mehr äh dass man doch jetzt mal mehr produzieren soll, ja, als müsste man irgendwo nur so ein, an so einem Rad drehen und dann kommt,
Impfstoff bei raus. Ja und das ist ja irgendwie ganz einfach wäre, das sind da so die typischen Wortmeldungen von Christian Lindner oder sowas. Ähm na ja so einfach ist es eine Nummer nicht, weil es handelt sich hier eben um einen neuen Impfstoff.
Die Technologie, die musst du halt auch erstmal aufbauen. Also es wird jetzt wohl eine neue Fabrik, die glaube ich vorher,
Ingelheim gehört hat, die Björn Tichetz übernimmt in Marburg, die wird jetzt irgendwie aufgebaut und wird dann so ab März auch nochmal irgendwie sechzig Millionen äh Dosierungen
pro Monat äh rausproduzieren, wenn das alles richtig anläuft. Aber es ist halt jetzt nicht mal so ohne Weiteres skalierbar.
Also nicht ohne weiteres. Also und auch nicht nur mit Geld, sondern du brauchst Expertise, du brauchst Personal. Du brauchst die die Maschinen, du brauchst die Technik
die die muss da sein, die muss gebaut sein, die muss funktionieren, muss abgenommen sein. Du musst eine Fabrik haben, du musst einen Workflow haben, musst dann eine Personalorganisation haben
um mal eben sechzig Millionen Dosierungen zu machen, da drückst du nicht irgendwo 'n Button auf 'ne Webseite und dann fallen die unten bei raus.
Äh plus halt ganze Qualitätskontrolle äh und so weiter, die durchführen musst, weil ja das ähm nee, das ist klar und ich habe auch äh damit.
Gerechnet, dass äh ja äh dass sich das über Monate noch hinziehen wird bis wir maximale Produktionskapazitäten aufgebaut haben und ähm.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wir halt äh wahrscheinlich vor dem Sommer, Juni, Juli.
August erst dann wir sozusagen maximale Produktionskapazität erreicht haben werden und.
Dass es äh ja vor allem im März, ab März dann eher.
Nach oben geht, aber ich rechne nicht damit, dass wir bis März irgendwie ja, dass dass wir da.
'n Durchschnitt 'n Tagesdurchschnitt erreichen der.
Rein rechnerisch bis zum uns bis zum Herbst bringen würde. Das heißt wir müssen in den ersten drei Monaten, wenn wir einfach.
Viel, viel zu wenig, also unterdurchschnittlich haben und werden dann wahrscheinlich eher ab März oder April dann,
überdurchschnittlich viel impfen, wobei Durchschnitt heißt, sagen, wie viel müssten wir pro Tag impfen, damit wir vor Herbst durch sind. So,
auf die Quote, also im im Moment bei der aktuellen Quote, wenn du das hochrechnest, wird's wahrscheinlich zehn Jahre dauern, bis wir durch sind, aber das bleibt halt nicht so.
Ja, müssen wir mal schauen. Also ich
glaubt zwar daran, dass in dem Moment, wo genug Impfstoff vorhanden ist, es uns auch gelingen kann, die diese ganze Produktivität der Impfzentren zu steigern und da wird der Druck der Öffentlichkeit auch äh sein übriges tun.
Nur da sind wir jetzt noch nicht. Also wir werden sehen, ne? Vierhundert Impfzentren in Deutschland.
Fünftausend pro Tag macht, dann dann wird sich da auch ein bisschen was tun, aber.
Da wir vorhin diesen Punkt hatten mit Argumenten für und gegen Impfung.
Hab ich irgendwie einen schönen Artikel gefunden, der das so zusammenfasst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man an dieser Stelle mal ausführlich auf diese Argumente einfach mal eingehen sollten. Äh vielleicht lese ich das einfach mal so.
Vor ja weil vielleicht ganz ganz sinnvoll ist das auch einfach mal so in Ruhe mal einmal so zu durchdenken.
Mhm. Also sind eher nicht sind nicht Argumente für Impfungen, sondern erstmal Sankt Pseudoargumente, äh Gegenimpfungen, die aber nicht zutreffen. Richtig.
Also, du hast Recht, die.
Fragestellung, die immer aufgegriffen wird, ist mal das Gegenargument, ne? So, ja, ich sollte mich nicht impfen lassen, weil erster Punkt, weil man ja nur durch die Krankheit selbst, echte Immunität erreicht, ja?
Das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Nach einer Masernerkrankung,
Etwa ist das Immunsystem so geschwächt, dass über mehrere Jahre das Risiko für den Tod durch andere Infektionskrankenhalten erhöht ist
also auch diese Schwächung des Immunsystems ist hier so ein Faktor. Wer sich hingegen beispielsweise jedes Jahr gegen Grippe impfen lässt, stärkt auf Dauer sein Immunsystem, weil der Körper,
so mit vielen verschiedenen Stimmen in Berührung kommt,
selbst wenn es ein Impfstoff ist, der in der aktuellen Saison nicht zu hundert Prozent gegen die grassierenden Stämme wirksam ist, wird die Grippe aufgrund der früheren Impfung milder verlaufen.
Zweites Gegenargument, weil eine Impfung das Immunsystem überfordert. Ja, eine Impfung kann Nebenwirkungen haben, die Einstichstelle schmerzt, es kommt zu Fieber.
Oder einer leichten Form jeder Erkrankung gegen die geimpft wurde, doch genau das zeigt, dass das Immunsystem tut, was es soll. Denn ein Impfstoff stellt den Körper abgeschwächte Krankheitserreger oder Teile davon zum Abwehrtraining zur Verfügung,
Eine Impfreaktion ist eine Art Probealarm,
Genau das ist es, was unsere Abwehr stärker macht. Im Ernstfall sind unsere weißen Blutkörperchen dann gewappnet und können eingedrungene Viren und Bakterien schnell überwältigen.
Auch das Immunsystem von Kindern wird durch Impfung nicht überfordert, alle Immunisierungen, die sie in den ersten Lebensjahren bekommen, enthalten, zusammengenommen, insgesamt einhundertfünfzig Antigene,
Früher waren es wesentlich mehr, weil Impfungen immer besser werden. Tatsächlich setzt sich das kindliche Immunsystem,
für diese Aufgabe gut gerüstet ist, tagtäglich mit einer vielfach größeren Menge von Antigen auseinander als dies bei Impfung der Fall ist. Schreibt das RKI.
Ja? Also da vielleicht auch zu sagen ähm dass ja Verträglichkeit von Impfungen. So erst einmal feststellen, ja es gibt auch Impfschäden.
So, es kommt vor, dass äh ja Leute Impfungen nicht gut vertragen, aber.
Ist auch der Spruch okay, äh, wenn du halt den Impfstoff nicht verträgst, dann probier mal das Virus äh so, dann müsst ihr schon sehen äh.
Wie das läuft. Also das ist sozusagen ein ein Ding. Ja, also wenn eine Impfung des Immunsystem überfordert, dann äh überfordert eine Erkrankung des Immunsystem, aber mal äh.
Ja nochmal viel, viel krasser. Nichtsdestotrotz vielleicht als als Tipp äh wenn man sich denn impfen lässt und,
Befürchtung hat, dass es einem irgendwie nicht gut tut
ähm sollte man sich einfach nach der Impfung vielleicht zwei, drei Tage frei nehmen oder sich krank schreiben lassen oder das zulegen, dass man halt zwei, drei Tage nach der Impfung einfach Ruhe hat, weil was man nämlich auch weiß, ist,
dass äh ja Stress und äh eben.
Schlechter, allgemeiner Gesundheitszustand nicht gut sind. Also auch wenn man irgendwie erkältet sein sollte oder sich gerade einfach
sowieso schlapp oder krank fühlt, dass man dann vielleicht äh auch ein bisschen wartet, bis man, bis man wieder fit ist, so äh eine Woche oder zwei, aber auf jeden Fall, dass man.
Sollte jetzt nach Möglichkeit vermeiden sich impfen zu lassen und dann vielleicht noch dann auf am nächsten Tag auf Geschäftsreise zu gehen und irgendwie über den Globus zu jetten und äh sowas zu tun, das ist.
Zwar jetzt auch nicht schlimm, aber ähm man sollte es vermeiden, wenn man das Gefühl hat.
Man verträgt Impfungen nicht gut. So, aber wie gesagt, äh wenn man Impfungen nicht gut verträgt, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ähm Krankheiten da.
Viel mehr zusetzen, doch deutlich größer und.
Der andere Punkt, der dort auch kurz angeklungen ist. Impfstoffe gibt's jetzt, was seit hundert Jahren oder so und.
Ersten Impfstoffe, die man auch äh verimpft hat, selbst noch in den sechziger, siebziger, achtziger Jahren äh.
Des letzten Jahrhunderts waren wesentlich schmutziger, ja, sagen die enthielten viel mehr
unerwünschte Proteine, die man zwar versucht rauszufiltern, aber äh heute sind die Impfstoffe einfach viel, viel besser geworden, weil dieses sagen dieses Argument eben auch an,
klingt ja so Mehrfachimpfungen oder viele Stoffe und nee, also wer äh.
Da schon vor fünfzig Jahren Leute, Impfstoffe.
Überstanden haben, die wo du dich heute mit den, mit derselben Menge an.
Protein wahrscheinlich gegen einen Dutzend oder zwei Dutzend Krankheiten gleichzeitig impfen lassen könntest. So ähm ja.
Also kann ich aus meiner Erkenntnislage nur.
Beipflichten, dass dem so ist.
Gut, machen wir weiter.
Müssen wir nicht alles äh äh komplett äh durchlesen, oder?
Nicht unbedingt alles kommentieren, aber es ähm ich ich fand das mal ganz ganz.
Mhm. Okay.
Dieser Argument äh Perspektiven mal zu machen, ne? So hier, ne? Äh so ich fühle mich nicht impfen lassen, weil ich es selbst auch gehabt habe. Also sie hatten Glück, viele Infektionskrankheiten heilen aus und bleiben ohne Folgen, doch in manchen Fällen können diese Erkrankungen dramatisch verlaufen.
So erkrankt etwa eines von tausend Kindern mit Masern an der sogenannten Masern in Cefalitis. Sie führt häufig zu Hirnschäden oder zum Tod.
Statistik zeigt eindrücklich, dass früher bevor gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft wurde, die Kindersterblichkeit wesentlich höher war als heute mit verbesserter Hygiene, wie oft argumentiert wird, hat das nur wenig zu tun. Etwa bei den Masern entwickelt fast jeder und jeder,
Erkrankung, die oder die ungeschützt ist und das Virus aufnimmt, egal wie gut die Hygienemaßnahmen sind. So, also.
Man sollte sich auch impfen lassen, wenn man, wenn man Kowit gehabt hat, so, ne. Das äh zeigt sich auch, dass die.
Immunreaktion auf die Impfung nochmal sehr viel besser und stärker ist als die durch die Krankheit selber und das ist auch der Punkt. Man kann sich ja auch so ein bisschen infizieren. Also so,
Wenn man so in der ungünstigen Situation war, dass man so lautes Gespräch und man nimmt so richtig äh tief Luft und kriegt das also so richtig volle Dröhnungen mit hurra hoher Viruslast,
in die Lunge. So das sind dann so auch dann die schlimmsten Verläufe.
Weil einfach der Virus sich an so vielen Stellen schon andocken äh konnte, so groß verteilt ist, sodass es Immunsystem überhaupt gar keine Chance hat, während wenn man jetzt so so ein bisschen was durch die Nase aufgenommen hat, in geringen Mengen, das Virus erstmal eine Weile braucht, um sich überhaupt.
Zur Replizieren, das Immunsystem aber in dem Moment schon Winter von bekommt und dann eben gegen ankämpft, dann ist das halt ein Garant für einen schwachen Verlauf, aber dann bildet sich eben auch diese Immunreaktion nicht so stark ab.
Und deswegen macht es einfach Sinn an so einer Impfung noch teilzuhaben, ne.
Ja. Ja, das war ja auch, ich glaube, es in einem Drosten-Podcasts ähm Anfang war halt, dass manche Leute einfach nur, ich sage mal, sowas wie eine Teilimmunität ausbilden, beziehungsweise nur bestimmte Arten von Antikörpern
entwickeln.
Und eben nicht sagen das volle Spektrum, weil deren Immunsystem möglicherweise unterfordert ist, äh mit seiner leichten Erkrankung und sich dann eben nicht so.
Punkt, ich will mich nicht impfen lassen, weil Kranksein zum Leben gehört und Kinder diese Erfahrung machen müssen.
Findet großartig.
Ja, ja, äh ja, natürlich gehören Krankheiten zum Leben, etwa ein gebrochener Fuß oder eine Erkältung. Möglicherweise gibt es positive Lehren, die sich daraus ziehen lassen, etwa mehr Vorsicht auf dem Spielplatz, doch sicherlich nicht gemeint sind Infektionskrankheiten
die die Gesundheit langfristig schwächen. Kinder in ihrer Entwicklung zurückwerfen und die erfolgreich mit einer.
Impfung, die mit erfolgreich mit einer Impfung verhindert werden können. Es gibt keinerlei Hinweise dafür, dass nicht geimpfte Kinder sich besser entwickeln als Geimpfte. Das Gegenteil ist der Fall, denn jede Impfung trainiert und verbessert das Immunsystem,
Also das ist auch so ein Ding, ne? So so,
traditionelle Wahrnehmung von Haar, nee, das muss jetzt alles ganz natürlich verlaufen und äh Masernparty und äh.
Dann ja, ich will mich nicht impfen lassen, weil ich Entscheidungen für mein Leben selbst treffe.
Ja, Entscheidung über das eigene Leben sollte jeder und jede selbst treffen, doch die Entscheidung sich nicht impfen zu lassen hat nicht nur Auswirkung auf einen selbst, sondern auch auf das eigene Umfeld, denn wer sich impfen lässt, schützt auch diejenigen, die nicht.
Selbst geimpft werden können, weil sie zu jung, krank oder schwanger sind.
Impfung bedeutet also auch, sich um seine Mitmenschen zu kümmern, sich solidarisch zu zeigen und ist ein Beitrag für eine gesunde Gesellschaft, die in jeder oder jeder leisten kann. Ist ein guter Punkt, ne? Man muss bedenken, auch die aktuelle Impfung.
Ist erstmal nicht für Kinder unter sechzehn ist auch nicht angeraten bei Schwangeren hat man glaube ich auch schon drüber gesprochen.
Ist natürlich ein Zustand der äh schneller weggeht als zwölf zu sein so aber trotzdem.
Gibt auf jeden Fall eine bestimmte Gruppe und äh das ist der Punkt.
Jetzt bin ich mir auch gerade nicht so sicher, ob ich hier die ganzen Listen äh die ganze Liste durchgehen lassen kann, das vielleicht mal so als Anklagen. Es kommen dann noch so die Klassiker hier, ich will mir nichts vom Staat äh auftrainieren lassen. Die Pharmafirmen wollen doch nur Geld verdienen.
Und Impfungen lösen ja Autoimmunerkrankungen, Allergien aus, äh.
Viele Krankheiten nicht mehr, man kann ja trotzdem krank werden und so weiter. Also äh sehr lesenswerter.
Artikel an dieser Stelle und äh sei euch in den Shownotzen nahegelegt, euch den mal durchzulesen oder weiterzureichen.
Also am Ende ich ich finde nach wie vor der der Punkt ähm wer.
Ja wer sich nicht äh impfen lassen will oder wer wer ähm ja Angst vor Impfschäden hat, äh ja sollte die Krankheit einfach mal ausprobieren äh oder.
Mal gucken, wie das so ist.
Ja genau, das ist eine ja einfach der der Punkt keine Impfung wirklich kein,
schlimmer sein als die Krankheit der einzige Punkt ist,
Natürlich, dass du bei vielen anderen Impfungen sagen kannst, na gut, wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass sich die Krankheit kriege, beziehungsweise wenn ich die gesamte Bevölkerung durchimpfe, habe ich natürlich mehr Fälle, als wenn ich eine Krankheit habe, die sich nur,
Minderheit verbreitet, aber gerade bei,
haben wir ja den Fall, dass äh wir ziemlich sicher sind, dass es fast jeder kriegen wird,
auf lange Sicht, wenn man sich nicht impfen lässt. Das heißt, da
spielt dieser Punkt äh nicht so die Rolle, wobei natürlich der Punkt nun wichtig ist, dass Impfstoffe extrem sicher sein müssen, wenn man da fünfzig oder sechzig Millionen mit äh Menschen mit impft.
Impfungen sind gut.
Impfungen sind gut, genau, eine Frage, die natürlich jetzt mit der ganzen Impfung immer noch mit zusammenhängt und da habe ich hier auch nochmal so ein.
Äh Pepa vielleicht ganz kurz, weiß nicht ganz genau, wie das so aktuell diskutiert wird, aber in Australien haben sie sich äh irgendwie auch nochmal angeschaut so bei Kandidaten, die Kowit neunzehn hatten und haben Blutproben genommen,
auch hier zeigt sich ein weiteres Mal, was man schon häufiger gelesen hat, dass also diese ganzen Antikörper mindestens acht Monate lang vorhalten.
Also sehr viel länger kann man jetzt sozusagen noch nicht sagen, weil so lange haben sie es ja noch nicht gehabt, ne. Und äh was man immer wieder sieht, ist, dass zwar der eigentliche Immunzellenanteil.
Nach ein paar Wochen zurückgeht, also dass jetzt die äh Antikörper, die jetzt aktiv den.
Das Protein, das Bike-Protein, das Virus sozusagen bekleben, wenn es kommt und dadurch eben inaktivieren. Die gehen dann zwar zurück.
Aber das Immunsystem hat ja diese B-Zellen, äh die Teil des Systems sind, das sind so diese Erinnerungszellen, die halt sehr schnell dann entsprechende Antikörper produzieren können, wenn sie gebraucht werden. Und das zeigt sich halt dann.
Die noch in großen Zahlen vorhanden sind,
und in dem Moment, wo man sich halt wirklich wieder äh diesen Virus ausgesetzt sieht, würden diese B-Zellen halt diese Antikörper sehr schnell produzieren können, weil die quasi schon den den Bauplan dafür,
in Erinnerung haben und genau dafür sind sie ja auch gemacht und bis heute.
Haben sich eigentlich dieses ganze Thema mit Reinfektion, mit Covet, ähm das war ja am Anfang schon ein paar Mal so, dass dass sowas beobachtet wurde, dass Leute, die negativ waren, dann wieder positiv waren, aber das waren dann eben einfach mehr Hinweise auf schlechte Tests,
oder falsche Betrachtung. Es gibt gute Hinweise darauf, dass diese Impfung auch lange anhält.
Wobei äh es schon, glaube, vereinzelt reinfektion gegeben hat, aber das äh sind dann.
In der Regel Leute die halt Probleme mit ihrem Immunsystem haben, die also eigentlich nie wirklich eine gute Immunität entwickelt äh äh haben und das sind aber.
Ja, das ist sehr selten. Das kommt kaum vor, aber in einzelnen Fällen äh äh hast du das schon.
So und da ist dann natürlich die Frage, es ist dann wirklich eine Reinfektion oder ist das dann wirklich ein neuer Ausbruch, aber ja, bei.
Einfach Millionen von Menschen aus halt Einzelfälle, aber die sagen.
Äh kaum was aus darüber, was man jetzt wahrscheinlich als normaler Mensch erfahren wird.
Ja und vor allem da spricht dann auch eben wieder viel für eine Impfung, die dann halt einfach das Immunsystem richtig schön stramm zieht und dann einfach sehr viel bessere äh Immunantwort äh liefert, wenn.
Das Immunsystem nicht sowieso so da niederliegt und nicht mehr in der Lage ist, richtig zu reagieren. Das ist so eine andere Sache.
Dann haben wir noch so zwei kleinere Meldungen. Zunächst einmal wir haben ja bisher den Impfstoff von Biontech.
Der existiert, der ist zugelassen. Jetzt in den nächsten Tagen müsste eigentlich auch der.
Moderner RNA-Impfstoff zur Sprache kommen bei der IMA, bei der European Minical Social Silber und so. Was bedeutet EMA, EMA bedeutet European.
Medizin, Medi, Middy, was mit Medi.
Medicines Agency, genau, europäische Arzneimittelagentur und ich gehe mal davon aus.
Dass das auch auf nichts anderes hinauslaufen wird als eine unmittelbare Zulassung. Und dann gibt's aber noch diesen.
Impfstoff von Astra Ceneca, auf den ja auch Deutschland so ein bisschen mithofft.
Und der ist wohl noch nicht so weit. Also, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist da noch kein Antrag eingereicht worden und das wird definitiv im Januar nichts werden. Also ich denke mal,
bis äh der nach Europa kommt,
noch ein bisschen Zeit vergehen, sind da noch ein paar Fragezeichen übrig von ihrem komischen Phase drei Test und ja bin gespannt.
Dauert.
Ich meine bei dem Astra Senika-Impfstoff habe ich jetzt auch schon drüber nachgedacht. Ich meine, das ist ja der muss sagen.
Klassische oder ein klassischer Impfstoff, wenn ich das.
Mhm. Genau, a genovieren.
Dann für wenig Geld in großen Mengen herstellen lässt. Der wo irgendwie die Dosis eins fünfzig kostet und irgendwie auch nur im normalen Kühlschrank aufbewahrt werden muss dafür.
Scheint der nach ersten Erkenntnissen nicht ganz so gut zu sein wie die RNA äh Impfstoffe äh wobei.
Weißt du da Näheres drüber.
Also es, das ist ja dieser Fall mit die haben diese hatten da schon drüber berichtet, wo der ähm erste Testlauf ungefähr so eine sechzigprozentige Wirkung gezeigt hat oder fünfundsechzig.
Lief so mit zwei gleich äh großgegebenen Dosierungen und dann hatten sie eben durch diesen technischen Unfall oder vielleicht war es auch doch Absicht, man weiß nicht ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall hatten sie noch diese zweite kleinere Reihe.
Wo sie dann ähm in der ersten Phase oder bei der ersten Impfung,
Nur die Hälfte des Impfstoffs gegeben haben und danach äh die größere Menge und da hatten sie dann eine größere Ausbeute, aber da waren dann die Testzahlen relativ klein. Und das sollte irgendwie alles nochmal nachgeprüft werden.
Da habe ich jetzt noch nichts weiter zu gehört, ob da schon wirklich neue Ergebnisse vorliegen. In UK haben sie den Impfstoff halt mittlerweile zugelassen.
Tja, äh kann ich dazu nur sagen, so verflucht sei, wer Böses darüber denkt, so UK lässt den UK Impfstoff zu, äh, ganz schnell, obwohl andere das noch skeptisch sehen,
Ich werde nachher nochmal nochmal was zu.
Zulassungsmethoden und wie man da künftig zugeht vorgehen sollte, nochmal was zu sagen. Ich will mir da jetzt keine Meinung zugestehen in diesem Bereich. Tatsache ist nur.
Die tatsächliche Wirksamkeit dieses Impfstoffs hat noch so ein Fragezeichen, ist auf jeden Fall wirksam, insbesondere.
Im Vergleich zu dem, was bis vor einem Jahr als wirksamer Ilmpfoff.
Mhm. Mhm.
Ja, also da ist man generell, wenn irgendwas zu fünfzig Prozent wirkt, dann sagt man Halleluja und wir bewegen uns jetzt hier durch diese RNA-Impfstoffe, die einfach gleich so vom Start weg mit fünfundneunzig Prozentigen Werten äh äh,
geprescht sind, bewegt man sich schon da an ganz anderen Welt.
Was natürlich nochmal interessante oder ja unschöne Fragen natürlich aufwirft äh äh angenommen, du hast.
Auswahl zwischen.
Einem Stimpfstoff, der ich sag mal zu achtzig Prozent dich schützt und einem, der dich vor fünfundneunzig Prozent schützt, ähm tja ähm.
Genau, hier haben wir unseren Discount im Stoff. Der ist voll im gut im Angebot. Wir haben gute Lagerbestände oder hier müssten sie noch eine Woche warten. Für unser Premiumprodukt irgendwie.
Beides kostet sie beide, es ist nix.
Ja deswegen hoffe ich ja noch, dass diese abschließenden Phase drei Tests, die sie dort machen, dann nochmal andere Ergebnisse äh bringt, so das ist.
Derzeit einfach noch ein bisschen schwierig.
Ja, ich und ich frage mich natürlich auch.
Also auch das Problem, was wir vorhatten mit dem neuen Virus-Strang, der dann möglicherweise eine höhere, einen höheren Anteil,
der Bevölkerung braucht, um Herdenimmunität zu erreichen. Ähm.
Wenn du dann nur einen Impfstoff hast, der
ich sage mal zu sechzig Prozent hilft oder siebzig Prozent. Du brauchst aber jetzt achtzig Prozent um nochmal Zahlen reinzuwerfen, die Immun sein müssen, dann,
ist es natürlich auch vor dem Hintergrund kann das ein Problem sein, dass mit einem schlechteren Impfstoff vielleicht gar nicht die Herdenimmunität
erreichst oder viel, nochmal viel später erreichst so und das geht mir gerade halt durch den durch den Kopf, wobei sicherlich äh ja.
Der Impfstoff wahrscheinlich vor die Frage gestellt, lässt man sich dann, wenn der eine verfügbar ist und der andere nicht,
würde ich wahrscheinlich, wenn ich auf den anderen im Stoff,
zu lange warten müsste, sagen wir Monate würde ich mich wahrscheinlich auch lieber äh mit dem nicht ganz so wirksamen Impfstoff äh impfen lassen, aber.
Herden vor dem Hintergrund Herdenimmunität äh erreicht man die natürlich schneller mit einem Wirkstoff, der zu fünfundneunzig Prozent.
Schützt und aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wir halt auch die interessante Frage, wie wie viel Prozent
denn jetzt vor schweren Verläufen geschützt sind bei dem Astra Senika
Impfstoff, weil das scheint ja bei dem RNA-Impfstoff bisher hundert Prozent gewesen zu sein. Also da gab's ja wohl nicht einen einzigen schweren Verlauf bei den Leuten, die äh mit den RNA-Impfstoffen geimpft wurden und.
Wie das.
Ich meine sogar, dass das auch bei dem Astra Senika so war.
Ich gucke gerade mal hier in unserer äh keine schweren Fälle, bei denen die geimpft wurden. Also das war da auch so.
Ja. Also das wäre dann vielleicht auch eher ein ein Argument oder auch das wäre dann auch noch ein Argument dafür,
sagen okay, selbst wenn ich jetzt nicht den schönen Rennar-Impfstoff äh kriege, bin ich auf jeden Fall mit dem Astra Senika-Impfstoff von einem
schweren Verlauf geschützt, so das alleine wäre ja schon mal fast der wichtigste Punkt.
Gut. Dann noch so eine Sache mit ähm wie gehen wir denn jetzt sozusagen mit Impfungen um.
Aus Spanien kommt die Nachricht.
Sie äh planen, wo ihr merkt, dass es so ein Plan von dem man erstmal gucken muss, ob der dann auch tatsächlich so umgesetzt wird, aber ich fand, fand den Gedanken schon ganz krass, äh dass sie einen Register machen wollen.
Quasi weniger von Leuten, die sich haben impfen lassen, sondern mehr so von Leuten, die sich nicht haben impfen lassen, was letzten Endes natürlich aufs Gleiche hinauslauft. Ähm,
und davon die Rede war, dass anderen Ländern zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Also puh ähm.
Schauen wir mal, was da so ein bisschen mit verbunden ist, ist diese diese ganze Debatte mit äh soll man jetzt sozusagen irgendeinen Vorteil davon haben, dass man geimpft wurde oder sollte man irgendeinen Nachteil davon haben, dass man nicht geimpft wird,
Und das natürlich irgendwie interessanter, sozialer Sprengstoff an der Stelle, als natürlich äh.
Für beide Modelle gute Argumente gibt, warum man das nicht machen sollte. So deine Meinung zum.
Ja, ich meine ich wurde gerade historisch glaube ich.
So, ich meine es gibt natürlich das Thema Impfpflicht so und.
Die kann halt tatsächlich gesetzlich angeordnet werden so.
Also es gibt 'ne Rechtsgrundlage dafür aber meines Wissens ist es noch nie gemacht worden.
Doch für Masern.
Ja unter bestimmten Bedingungen glaube ich.
Kinder einschulen und sowas.
Genau, in Kindertagesstätten und Schulen äh sagen die Masern äh Impfung und in Brandenburg gibt's wohl eine allgemeine Masernimpfpflicht, aber die ist wohl noch nicht umgesetzt. So, das ist alles auch erst,
relativ neu und äh eine Impfpflicht,
noch unklar, o,
jetzt die Impfung beispielsweise Gastronomie oder Fluggesellschaften oder Veranstalter den Nachweis einer Impfung fordern dürfen, tendenziell eher nicht, denke ich mal, aber
sich jetzt auch die Geschichte der der.
Der Impfungen so in in Deutschland. Ich weiß gar nicht, hatten wir das in der letzten Sendung schon, dass das Thema, wie das mit der Schluckimpfung eigentlich gelaufen.
Ist. Es ist sozusagen interessante, interessante, historische Rückblick. Das war nämlich damals sehr, sehr.
Holprig, dass ich eben auch noch erinnern damals Schluckimpfung äh ist süß, also Kinderlähmung ist grausam, Schluckimpfung, es ist süß, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich da noch dran erinnern.
Oh ja, sehr wohl. Also das ja ja, das waren diese Fernsehspots, die könnte, hatte jeder im Ohr.
Das war dann auch schon der zweite Anlauf. Also er ist auch also im ersten äh ist kurz gesagt, als der erste Impfstoff äh,
rauskam, der halt gespritzt werden musste, war erstmal die Nachfrage sehr hoch, dann ist ein bisschen was schief gegangen, woraufhin dann ganz viele Leute Panik gekriegt haben und sich dann nicht mehr haben impfen lassen, ne? Man,
Anlauf halt mit der Schluckimpfung gemacht, wobei das Krasse, weil der Schluckimpfung war.
Dass du dadurch ansteckend werden konntest, ja? Weil.
Wenn du dich hast impfen lassen, war es dann möglich für eine gewisse Zeit eventuell andere Leute mit Kinderlehmung anzustecken
So, das war wohl nur bei der Schluckimpfung der Fall, nicht bei dann äh der der Spritze so, aber
trotzdem hat man's dann am Ende durchgezogen, hat's dann funktioniert, aber es ist halt auch alles nicht wirklich so
unproblematisch gelaufen, so.
Und äh ja und dagegen ist natürlich jetzt die Kovitung, man überlegt ja mal, äh wenn's
jetzt eine Kowidimpfung äh gebe und die würde dich aber dann jetzt für ein paar Tage potentiell ansteckend machen. Äh dann hätten wir eine ganz andere Debatte,
ne, aber trotzdem hat man es im Fall von Kinderlähmung äh damals in Kauf genommen.
Naja gut, ich denke, wir werden das einfach mal so ein bisschen äh begleiten. Es ist klar, dass das derzeit noch kein äh Thema ist, es ist vielfach gesagt worden, dass man das nicht äh tun will, wie Spanien da jetzt äh vorangeht. Das könnte nochmal interessant werden. Ich meine, es ist.
Wenn ich jetzt mal zum Beispiel eine Perspektive einnehme also so eine Branche, die jetzt besonders betroffen war im letzten Jahr, ne? So Partyveranstalter.
Und jetzt kommt der Sommer.
Und das ist für viele so ein bisschen der Sommer der Entscheidung, weil sie äh vielleicht gerade soeben vermieden haben, sich nicht das Genick brechen zu lassen durch den komplett ausgefallenen Partysommer.
Jetzt eigentlich, wenn sie überhaupt noch eine Chance haben wollen, jetzt alles schon darauf hinplanen und alles auf die Karte setzen, dass in irgendeiner Form dieser Sommer.
In dieser Form wieder stattfinden kann. So.
Aber jetzt noch nicht absehbar ist, dass diese Impfung bis dahin irgendwie allgemein irgendeine Sicherheit herstellt, ne.
Wie gehst du damit jetzt um? Als privater Veranstalter. Dass du jetzt.
Ja. Wir gucken mal. Wird schon irgendwie hinhauen, so. Mache ich jetzt ganz abgesehen davon, dass sowas.
Generell natürlich noch untersagt werden könnte euch. Denke mal, wir gehen alle davon aus, so sagen wir mal so eine Party, die jetzt zu finden, Juli geplant ist. Kann.
Schon realistisch davon ausgehen, dass die Gesamtsituation auch in Deutschland so sein sollte, dass dass nicht alles verboten ist.
Trotzdem warst du unter Umständen noch so eine so eine Restgefahr. Sagst du dann.
OK Party ja? Gerne Tickets für alle so wenn ihr nachweisen könnt dass ihr geimpft worden seid könnt ihr auch kommen.
So, schließt die aus, die noch gar keine Gelegenheit hatten. Ist natürlich jetzt gerade bei jungen Besuchern relativ wahrscheinlich, weil die natürlich ganz hinten in der Kette sind.
Schwierig, ja? Andererseits äh für andere Veranstaltungen vielleicht mit höheren.
Äh Durchschnittsalter der Teilnahme. Schon wieder eine Option. Äh ist das dann zulässig,
so war's überhaupt zu fragen oder nicht? Öffentlich ist ja nochmal was anderes, aber privat, ich meine, ich kenne ja alle möglichen Regeln setzen, ich kann einen Türsteher hinstellen und sagen so, ja dann mir gefällt dein Gesicht nicht
Du kommst hier nicht rein, so, dann ist das meine Entscheidung, ich muss niemand an meiner Veranstaltung teilnehmen lassen. Ich kann ja im Prinzip beliebige Bedingungen aufstellen.
Mhm. Ja also schwieriges Thema äh auf.
Auf jeden Fall, ich meine, es ist sehr ähnlich äh wie.
Das Thema sollen jetzt immunitätsbescheinigungen für Leute aufgestellt werden, die die Krankheit schon durchgemacht haben. So da äh gab's ja einen ganz klares Nein äh dazu.
Und ich gehe mal davon aus, äh dass.
Ja, ich meine gut, die ist, du hast natürlich einen Impfpass so und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die Impfung auch äh dann in deinen Impfpass eingetragen wird oder du in da eintragen lassen.
Kannst.
Und damit im Gegensatz jetzt zu einer durchgemachten Krankheit, die nirgendwo jetzt erstmal standardmäßig eingetragen wird, hast du natürlich dann ein Dokument in der Hand
mit dem du das potentiell nachweisen kannst, dass du geimpft bist, was natürlich schon genau Tür und Tor für die Situation
öffnet, dass,
Leute einfach privat für Teilnahme an was auch immer Dinge fordern können eben gesagt also,
fordern können, dass du geimpft bist, wenn du teilnimmst, auch wenn das möglicherweise ungesetzlich sein.
Plus, ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass einige Länder das äh zur Voraussetzung machen könnten für die Einreise,
mir auch vorstellen, so gerade Länder, die da großen Wert drauf legen, was weiß ich, Neuseeland.
Waren die ganzen Zerokovic-Staaten, die werden Scheiß werden die tollen und dich reinlassen, wenn er nicht geimpft wirst.
So und.
Und das ist auch, ich meine, das ist ja auch heute schon so. Ich meine, wenn ich als ich nach äh Französisch Guinea geflogen bin, so ohne Gelbfieberimpfungen hätte ich da gar nicht erst antanzen äh können. Also das ist jetzt nichts Neues.
Das ist auch absolut nachvollziehbar. Ich meine hallo.
Pandemie, ja? Also ich meine äh das ist mal echt ein guter, ein guter Grund. Da äh Leute bevorzugt zu behandeln. So und ich sage dir äh Impfpflicht.
Für Mallorca. Und das Ding ist durch.
Ja
So, ja, willst du auf Malle? Dann brauchst du Stempel für dich. Dann ist aber ganz schnell vorbei mit mit äh Impf äh Zurückhaltung.
Ja also.
Ganz gut dazu kommen ist natürlich dann aber vor dem Hintergrund, dass nicht genug Impfstoff da ist, macht das die ganze Situation natürlich nochmal.
Ja Konfliktreicher, potentiell, konfliktreicher, weil das natürlich dann auch ja äh.
So eine so eine Impfung dann wichtig ist für Einkommenserwerb und überhaupt äh so und.
Aber die Nachteile ohne das sind ja eh für alle noch viel schlimmer. Also von daher die die Situation kann sich einfach nur verbessern. Und ich find's
fast ein bisschen albern darauf rumzureiten und in gewisser Hinsicht ist es vielleicht auch ein Hebel, mit dem man diese Sache auch einfach mal beschleunigen kann. Weil das wir uns jetzt sozusagen auf die Einsicht
der Masse nicht so richtig verlassen können in unseren Kulturbreiten. Das haben wir jetzt einfach dieses Jahr schön gezeigt bekommen
Wir haben einfach dieses Mindset nicht. Wir sind einfach pandemisch noch nicht genug angeschlagen. Da hat Asien uns einfach,
großen äh weiten Schritt voraus ist, es ist uns einen großen und weiten Schritt voraus. Einfach, weil die das schon ein paar Mal gehabt haben.
Ja diverse Virus,
Epidemien hat es dort gegeben und sind schon bekämpft worden und es ist halt einfach äh eine andere Herangehensweise. Und die haben wir halt einfach noch nicht. Und die müssen wir jetzt wahrscheinlich einfach erlernen und von daher werde ich da durchaus,
nicht überrascht, wenn im privaten Bereich solche Forderungen gestellt werden, wenn wir im Einreisebereich von anderen Ländern so etwas sehen und dass das dann am Ende auch wirklich der Katalysator ist, der da die Leute dazu bringt, sich irgendwie impfen zu lassen.
Gut. Lange Sendung haben wir schon, aber wir haben noch ein paar ganz goldene Themen drauf und deswegen,
Würde ich sagen, machen wir mal an dieser Stelle äh weiter und zwar möchte ich jetzt hier kurz mit Feedback kommen
wir freundlicherweise von euch bekommen haben umfangreich in den Kommentaren, da steht überhaupt 'ne ganze Menge, ich kann das jetzt nicht alles wiedergeben, aber vielleicht zwei Sachen zum Thema
Vitamin D. Ich hatte ja diesen Vortrag mir dort angeschaut und versucht zu verstehen und hier wieder zu geben.
Um mal zu berichten, was in dem Bereich so geforscht wird und dazu hat uns ähm ja Feedback äh erlangt. Kurz,
werde die letzte Sendung nicht gehört hat. Es ging ja da drum die Frage, welchen Einfluss kann hat unter Umständen,
Vitamin D und speziell ein bestimmter Vitamin D Level im Körper auf Cowitterkrankungen und kann man da irgendwie was äh draus ablesen.
Und da,
erreichte uns unter anderem Feedback von Stefan und er schreibt lieber Pavel lieber Tim, Vitamin D ist ein vielschichtiges Minenfeld. Ich kann euch dann nur sagen, dass selbst
Ärzte, die sich als reflektiertsehender einen Fall laufen. Es fängt tatsächlich ganz am Anfang an. Zwanzig elf wurden die Grenzwerte fest,
die Arbeitsgruppe drückte sich sehr umständlich aus und so wurden die Grenzwerte von interessierter Seite sehr hoch angesetzt. Ein Jahr später versuchte die gleiche Arbeitsgruppe die Grenzwerte wieder einzufangen
Was sie aber gründlich bislang seither schwirren sie durch den Raum und sind falsch. Wenn ich diesbezüglich und der Quellen auf Twitter verweisen dürfte, link.
Ganz aktuell ist die Frage, ob Vitamin D, Athenwix Infekte reduzieren kann, nicht beantwortet, eine aktuelle Meteranalyse zeigt Hauchdünn ja an, wenn man genau hinschaut, sieht man aber
dass das Jahr durch viele kleine Jahrs, kleine Studien zustande kommt, die paar großen Klopper mit vielen Fällen sagen alle kein Vorteil
mit passenden Link dazu. Niedrige Vitamin D Spiegel sind schon mit lange bekannt als Korrelation mit Armut, Krankheit, Bildungsferne et cetera. Ganz banal kann man sich die Frage stellen
Wer nimmt täglich Vitamin D zu sich äh in einer Pandemie, das sind nicht die dicken, rauchenden, diabetischen Armen in der Sozialwohnung mit acht Geschwistern,
blöd es klingt, jemand der in der Lage ist, sich zu informieren, sich etwas zu kaufen und dann auch noch täglich zu nehmen, ist allein durch diese Fähigkeiten weniger durch Kowit gefährdet, weil er dann vermutlich auch noch begreift, wie wichtig
Aha Strich L ist und den Platz hat dies auch umzusetzen. Da Vitamin D fest in den Händen der Bullshit Mafia ist, werden positive Studien,
auch nur so klingende Studien oft und gerne geteilt, negative Ergebnisse jedoch ignoriert und mit ganz anderen Maßstäben betrachtet wie die positiven Ergebnisse,
ein weiterer Link. Es ist nichts dagegen einzuwenden, Vitamin D einen vernünftigen Dosen zu nehmen, das sind achthundert bis tausend E pro Tag,
Damit beugt man einem mangel zuverlässig vor, Ende der Magie, man sollte aber weder seinen Spiegel bestimmen.
Sind sehr unzuverlässig, noch ist als Fehler kommunizieren,
Vitamin D nicht zu nehmen oder zu geben. Derzeit spricht mehr dafür, dass es selbst für klassische Integration nicht hilft.
Als dass es hilft. Übrigens haben Dicke nicht deswegen einen niedrigen Vitamin D Spiegel, weil sie viel Fettgewebe haben. Das Fett wird so langsam gebildet, dass das Vitamin D es sättigen kann.
Dadurch kein Nachteil entsteht, sondern dicke Lieben einfach im Schnitt,
ungesunder bewegen sich weniger, gehen weniger in die Sonne und so weiter. Äh seine Fettlöslichkeit, also die das Vitamin D ist aber auch seine Stärke, während Vitamin C immer sofort wieder ausgepinkelt wird, kann Vitamin D über Monate.
Also auch in der Winterzeit im Körper verbleiben und defundiert aus den Feldzellen ins Blut, wenn dort der Spiegel sinkt.
Daher kommen wir im Gegensatz zum fünfunddreißig Grad Bullshit auch über das Jahr ganz gut ohne extra D aus, wenn denn in den Sommermoden und
Monaten unser Verhalten stimmt, eure Verwirrung mit Haut lieber Niere ist übrigens verständlich, in der Haut entsteht Vitamin D drei. Dann in der Leber fünfundzwanzig OH Vitamin D drei und schließlich in die Nieren. Das eins Komma zwo fünf Dehoxy,
die die Hydroxi Vitamin D PS. Natürlich ist Rauchen ein Risikofaktor. Noch ein Link. Also alles anders.
Und das hatte ich ja auch schon.
Eingangs gesagt, dass dass man sozusagen davon auch ausgehen äh kann und mit jedem weiteren Kommentar kriegt man hier.
Weitere Einblicke. Ähm ich belasse es jetzt vielleicht mal hier dabei. Es gibt noch ein paar andere äh Kommentare, die sich damit auseinandersetzen und äh.
Gut es steht aber jetzt eher auch nicht komplett.
Äh im Gegensatz zu dem, was wir, glaube ich, in der letzten Sendung äh äh gesagt hatten, sondern also ich erinnere mich äh unsere Konklusion war äh ja, wenn man
äh wenn man Vitamin D Mangel hat äh und den beseitigt, dann dürfte das wahrscheinlich helfen. So.
Aber sich irgendwie mit Vitamin D voll zu hauen, so schützt jetzt nicht davor, wenn man eigentlich vorher schon.
Genug davon hatte, dann.
Macht das äh vermutlich keinen großen Unterschied. Also ich glaube, das war, was wir in der letzten Sendung gesagt haben und.
Die Kommentare äh sagen mir da jetzt nichts anderes, was vielleicht noch wichtig war, der Punkt, dass offensichtlich die.
Grenzwerte, wo es noch gesund ist oder nicht ungesund wird, sehr hoch,
angesetzt zu sein, scheinen und das nicht unbedingt eine gute fachliche Grundlage hat, aber das hatten wir zwar so nicht nicht erwähnt, aber ähm ja.
Dass die offiziellen Grenzwerte sehr hoch sind. Das war so ein, so ein,
so ein Punkt, äh wo man sagen kann, gut, weil man soll's vielleicht dann doch nicht äh so sehr übertreiben oder davon ausgehen, dass die Grenzwerte, die genannt worden sind, wirklich,
sicher äh oder völlig unschädlich oder unbedenklich.
Das denke ich äh würde ich jetzt aus dem Kommentar mal ziehen, für den ich mich auch nochmal.
Bedanken möchte, klingt für mich schon so, als wenn da jemand sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt hat.
Gut, für die weiteren Kommentare verweise ich äh auf den, ja, auf die Kommentare im Blog und äh freue mich natürlich über jegliches weiteres äh Feedback.
So jetzt jetzt doch so eine kleine Perle. Ich hoffe.
Dass es mir überhaupt gelingt, das hier in dem Podcast irgendwie richtig darzustellen, weil in gewisser Hinsicht.
Kann ich das jetzt auch nicht. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein Artikel, den man sich mal anschauen sollte. Insbesondere
wenn man äh selbst sich so als Nerd oder Informatiker oder Computeraffin oder eben Programmierer oder so äh sieht
oder zumindest als in entsprechend interessiert sieht. Und zwar ist das ein Artikel von äh wie heißt der Berthold? Bert Hubert oder so, der ähm
sich mal das Biontech Pfeiser äh äh wachzin, angeschaut hat.
Und dessen Funktion auf eine Art und Weise beschreibt, wie das so Programmierer mit ihren Programmen tun würden,
Und äh was dabei überhaupt schon mal erstaunlich ist, ist, dass man,
auf dieser mit dieser Betrachtungsweise dem dem Wesen, des Immunsystems oder auch wie wieso Viren funktionieren, wieso RNA und DNA funktioniert doch sehr,
nahe kommen kann. Es ist überhaupt, ich meine, ich hatte es ganz lustig, ich hatte in diesem Sommer auf irgend so einer.
Party, so eine Sommerparty hatte ich auch so eine Diskussion mit so einer Frau, die auch so ein bisschen diese Position einnahm, na ja.
Ist ja immer alles natürlich sein und gibt dann auch mal so Leute, wenn man selber so ein bisschen darlegt, wie wie sehr,
die Computer und die Proamierungen und überhaupt die digitale Welt einen selbst so geprägt haben im Leben, ja? Und auch die Sicht auf die Dinger, ja, die sich dann auch schnell so ablehnen. Das war dann bei ihr auch diese Position. Nein und immer dieses digitale und so und
ich bin ja immer ganz natürlich sein und und das Wort analog kriegt dann auch immer nochmal so ein, so ein, so eine Blumeneinrahmung dabei.
Sage ich nur immer äh zu sowas, okay. Natürlich ist äh dass Menschen eine Lebenserwartung von fünfundzwanzig Jahren haben und äh die meisten Kinder halt äh
im ersten Jahr versterben und äh ja normal ist das Frauen zehn bis fünfzehn Kinder äh haben vielleicht äh so bis sie dann mit dreißig sterben. Das ist äh ja normal, das ist halt.
Natürlich, das ist halt äh ja.
Okay, auch eine interessante äh Gesichtspunkt, den hatte ich jetzt in dem Moment nicht angebracht, weil mir ging's dann äh um was anderes. Aber ich habe dann kurz nachgedacht und äh festgestellt so, ja, weißt du.
Auch wir sind extrem digital. So, DNA.
Das Leben, das Leben und zwar nicht nur unser Leben, sondern das Leben aller Lebewesen auf diesem Planeten basiert auf DNA und DNA ist einfach eine hochdigitale Information.
Nicht binär aber digital.
Nicht nicht pinär, aber digital äh ja in Schritten und in also in diskreten Werten äh die Welt beschreibend.
Ist kein statischer Zustand, es ist am laufenden Meter
ja? Durch Mutation und Weiterentwicklung, sprich Evolution, gegeben, aber die Definition von Leben ist
Beschreibung eines Apparats, eines wirklich eines extrem maschinellen Apparats, der sich mit ganz konkreten Programmcode beschäftigt und genau das ist das, was DNA macht.
Unser, unser äh unsere DNA äh diese Helix, ja, enthält schlicht Informationen, die kann man mit vier Buchstaben aufschreiben, also an jeder Stelle hast du einen von vier Buchstaben und
äh
Das beschreibt exakt genau die Baupläne für Proteine, die dann halt von den Zellen produziert werden und das ist halt genau das, was sozusagen unser Leben definiert und auch was uns selbst definiert.
Na ja, zurück zu diesem Artikel ähm.
Er nimmt also jetzt sozusagen diese offizielle äh Beschreibung.
Des ähm des Bike Proteins, dieses Virus,
Und wie die beschrieben ist und und und äh legt es sozusagen mal konkret da, was da exakt genau da eigentlich wirklich drinsteht,
Also was ist denn sozusagen in diesem Impfstoff
der ja letzten Endes nur dazu da ist in die Zelle einzudringen, dort diese RNA freizugeben, diese RNA wird dann von.
Quasi als Bauplan verwendet und setzt Aminosäuren zusammen.
Und daraus entsteht dann sozusagen also ein Strang, der sich dann im Nachgang zusammenfaltet zu einem Protein und das ist dann sozusagen etwas, was in dem Körper wirken kann. Und Proteine gibt's für alles Mögliche. Und in dem Fall,
soll eben der Impfstoff, den dieses Bike-Protein, dieses Stachelprotein des Virus.
Nachbilden und das dann eben einfach der Körper zwar keinen Virus ausgesetzt wird, aber trotzdem denselben Erkennungsmechanismus startet.
Ja und in dem Zusammenhang wird eben auch mal genau erklärt, was eigentlich passiert, ne? Beschreibt sozusagen das Ganze so als Source Code und das ist wirklich erstaunlich, weil es halt wirklich auf die unterste Ebene runtergeht. Also alles wird mit diesen vier,
Informationen beschrieben, also dass es dann irgendwie bei R und A ist das irgendwie A C GU.
Und äh nur mit diesen vier Buchstaben wird sozusagen das vollständige Verhalten beschrieben. Ich werde jetzt mal hier nicht so.
Einzelnen durch alles äh durchgehen, aber es ist wirklich super äh interessant zu sehen, wie wirklich Schritt für Schritt dieser Bauplan und dieser
der da läuft ähm beschrieben wird. So, im Wesentlichen ist es so, du hast halt so
wie so eine bei so einer Übertragung eines Datenpakets, wenn man, wie man das so kennt, wenn so Computer miteinander sprechen, ne, dann packst du ja auch deine Informationen etwas ein.
Du hast immer so ein so ein Headder, der erstmal sagt so, ja hier geht's los. Hier, hier, hier beginnt überhaupt erstmal eine Information.
Ja, was mir vielleicht äh, also was mir erstmal schon mal ganz gut gefällt,
so der Vergleich auch von DNA mit dass es die Festplatte oder die Farmware und die RNA ist halt mehr so der Arbeitsspeicher.
Ja, das fand ich schon mal einen ganz guten Vergleich, weil die DNA ist halt dieser Doppelstrang und der ist zu.
Und der ist halt sehr, sehr stabil. Kaja, wir wissen tausende von Jahren oder zigtausende von Jahren sogar,
stabil halten, aber
ist halt, weil der halt so lange der Zug ist äh kann man den auch nicht auslesen und Ren A ist dann quasi sowas wie Arbeitsspeicher, ein bisschen flüchtiger, also die wird halt
aus der DNA ausgeließen und sagen dann ein Stück Renn A produziert. Was aber dann eben
nicht so lange hält, also RNA deswegen halt auch diese extreme Kühlung bei den RNA äh stoffen, weil die halt nicht so stabil sind, weil das ist halt eine Kette
im Prinzip an äh ja und.
Ja, also den den Vergleich fand ich ziemlich gut und insbesondere, weil der vielleicht ein bisschen klar macht, dass jetzt der Impfstoff erstmal nicht,
meine DNA verändert, also es ist jetzt kein Patch für mein Betriebssystem, sondern dass es mehr, sondern Programm äh weiß ich nicht, was ich von Diskette lade und äh ausführe und
ja wenn ich den Computer ausmache ist aber auf dem Computer und auf der Festplatte erstmal also sprich in der DNA keine Spur.
Davon, das fand ich.
Das ist eine App. Der Impfstoff ist eine App.
Das ist so ein kleines Stück Rot, was du lädst und was irgendwie äh Sachen besser macht. Und genauso geht er dann eben da auch äh durch, ne? Also du hast um jetzt vielleicht nochmal auf diese,
diese eigentliche Funktion zurückzukommen, also in dem Moment, wo man geimpft wird so, ne? Tritt einfach dieser RNA-Strang von dem Impfstoff, tritt ein,
ist halt in so einer Fetthülle, mit der schafft das dann eben in irgendeine Zelle einzutreten und dann sagt die Zelle so, hallo.
Wer bist du denn? Ja, ich bin's, die RNA. Ich habe hier, ich habe hier so einen Bauerauftrag, ja.
Würdest du in irgend so eine irgend so eine Firma reinlaufen so in in den in den Produktionsbereich und einfach so tun als würdest du dazugehören und ja ich hab hier so 'n Auftrag von oben, na ja gib mal her, ich mach das mal so, ne?
Sozusagen der Trick. Er zeigt aber dann auch gleich, wo.
Problematisch ist, ne? Also äh abgesehen jetzt so von so ein bisschen Hedder-Information, gibt's dann sozusagen den eigentlichen Bauauftrag für dieses Protein.
Und er zeigt dann auch sehr schön, wie so ein paar Tricks angewendet werden müssen. Zum Beispiel, dass diese ganze RNA nicht vom,
vom Immunsystem von vorne rein schon weggetreten wird,
ja? Und dass das immer auf bestimmten Erkenntnissen beruht, die so in den letzten zehn Jahren irgendwann mal gefunden wurden. Also es man man sieht auch schon, wie bei der Entwicklung dieses Impfstoffs,
Kenntnisse der letzten Jahre hier jetzt endlich zum Tragen kommen in vollständiger Form. Äh und wie man den eben auch konkret sehen kann, ne? Also zum Beispiel, dass halt.
Das U wird immer durch ein leicht
geänderten, äh, durch eine leicht geänderte Variante, die dann zwar am Ende auch durch ein wie ein U interpretiert wird, aber von außen erstmal chemisch nicht aussieht wie ein O. Und das verhindert schon mal, dass diese RNA
vom Impfstoff gleich äh weggespült wird.
Dann ist natürlich auch die Frage, was wird letzten Endes gebaut? Was hat sich zum Beispiel gezeigt, dass wenn man jetzt den selben Bauplan nimmt, exakt eins zu eins genauso wie er im Virus steht für dieses Bike Protein.
Wirtswahl im Prinzip dieses Bike-Protein auch genauso gebaut. Aber dadurch, dass es eben nicht noch so ein Virus unten dran hat.
Faltet es sich anders und hat von daher dann doch eine andere Erkennungs äh Erscheinungsform,
und das Immunsystem würde eben nicht entsprechend richtig reagieren.
Sich halt anders darstellt, weil es irgendwie eine andere Erscheinung hat und dementsprechend sozusagen die Oberfläche, die Angriffsfläche auf einmal eine andere ist
Und das ist sozusagen, das ist äh das ist zum Beispiel eine Erkenntnis, die so ein Chinese vor ein paar Jahren äh hatte, was dann letzten Endes bei,
moderner ähm zum zum Tragen kam und das ist sozusagen eine Technik, die sich Biontech auch von moderner.
Äh darüber geholt hat. Man kann das sehr schön sehen, dass also hier der eigentliche Bauplan wir äh für das Bike-Protein, wir im Virus steht.
Weitgehend identisch ist, nur an zwei Stellen wird eben für eine andere Aminosäurenkombination kodiert und genau diese eine kleine Änderung,
die dieser chinesische Wissenschaftler,
einfach durch jahrelanges Ausprobieren irgendwann mal rausgefunden hat, das hat dann eigentlich dazu geführt, dass das überhaupt erst funktioniert.
Das kann man also einfach hier wunderbar sehen.
Finde überhaupt diese Vergleiche im Computer, sind super, ja? Also wo wir zum Beispiel üblicherweise ja immer alles zur Basis zwei haben, also Computerspinärsystem,
blicken wir ja sozusagen auf Werte von.
Also von von Stellen werden eben von null und bis eins, ja, das heißt du hast immer unterscheidest immer eine Null und eins und weil es ein bisschen unpraktisch ist für größere Informationsblöcke,
fasst man die dann halt in der Regel zu einem Bei zusammen, das sind dann eben acht BIT. Und dann hast du eben so 'ne
Kombinationsfähigkeit von null bis zweihundertfünfundfünfzig, also zweihundertsechsundfünfzig verschiedene Kodierungen.
Im Bauplan, im RNA, Bauplan sieht es eben ähnlich aus, nur dass wir eben jetzt hier nicht ein System zu Basis zwei hast, sondern zur Basis vier, also statt null eins hast du also dieses AU,
CG quasi als äh Zeichenvorrat und mal fast drei Stellen zusammen.
Du hast dann nicht zwei hoch acht, sondern du hast dann irgendwie vier hoch drei und ähm hast dann eben vierundsechzig verschiedene Kodierungen pro,
Das heißt dann nicht bald, sondern das heißt dann Kodonen und Kudon, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man's ausspricht.
Äh diese Kodons sind sozusagen so die die Informationsgruppen, indem du dann eben sagst, was jetzt hier als nächstes in der Kette gebaut werden soll, das heißt, Protein wird so Kodon für Kodon zusammengebaut,
Du hast dann so ein Mapping von so einem dieser äh dieser dreistelligen Werte auf bestimmte Aminosäuren. Da gibt's aber auch nur zwanzig,
bedeutet du hast verschiedene,
Gruppenwerte, die oft selber Aminosäure kodieren. Macht offenbar aber einen Unterschied, ob der Körper sozusagen das jetzt wieder als Angriff sieht oder nicht. Je nachdem, mit welchem Wert du etwas kodierst. Das heißt, du kannst dasselbe Ergebnis
erreichen, indem du es etwas anders beschreibst.
Zum Beispiel, dass eben im Virus ist es grundsätzlich im impfstoff, es ist generell gut, wenn äh möglichst viele
Stellen, das G verwenden,
Also umso mehr geht da drin ist, umso weniger wird es als Feind angesehen. Und dann guckst du halt immer, reicht die selbe Aminosäure eben auch mit einem Wert kodieren, der einen G enthält, dann nimmst du halt das.
Und dann funktioniert das irgendwie. Also ist wirklich sehr spannend, wer jetzt nicht hier weiter ins Detail reingehen. Auf jeden Fall kann man in dieser Beschreibung einerseits sehr schön absehen, wie unser ähm.
Bauplansystem tatsächlich funktioniert und eben auch welche Tricks und welche speziellen.
Erkenntnisse der letzten Jahre aus der Wissenschaft hier eingearbeitet wurden, um hier wirklich ein wunderbar arbeitendes Wagzin zu erstellen.
Ja, plus was wir halt auch noch machen kannst. Ähm also das halt einmal den Bauplan.
Das ist glaube ich, das war mal glaube ich jetzt ganz gut erklärt, aber,
RNA, die du da dann einschleust, kann auch noch sozusagen so was wie ja Anweisungen an die Zelle
enthalten die noch viel mehr machen zum Beispiel wie
kannst du dann in Marka reinbringen mit 'ner Anweisung an die Zelle und dieses Protein jetzt bitte dann aus der Zelle raus exprimieren
so. Oder.
Also wo es hingehen soll, ne? Gen.
Genau, also entweder sagen normalerweise wird sich standardmäßig dann in der Zelle ansammeln, bis sie irgendwann platzt. So, das willst du natürlich nicht
Ähm so deswegen hast du dann noch so weitere Sequenzen drin, die dann auch von Viren abgeguckt sind
und so, die dann der Zelle sagen und im Übrigen dieses Protein bleibt aber bitte nicht, sondern das geht halt jetzt raus und auch die Bedingungen, wann du das an oder ausschalten kannst. Du kannst also wirklich komplexe.
Logiken dort dort einbauen. Also es ist schon echt abgefahren.
Ist aber eben auch man, wenn du,
rein Software schreibst auf 'nem normalen System, hast du 'ne eher stabile Umgebung, du gehst davon aus, dass wenn dein Southcode richtig ist,
im Computer, dass der dann auch so ausgeführt.
Wird. Äh so. Wenn du jetzt dagegen hingehst und jetzt zum Beispiel äh einen Chip beschreibst, wenn du also jetzt statt.
Das mit einem gängigen Prozessor ausführen zu lassen, das sitzen programmierbaren Logikbausteinen und machst da jetzt eine Logik rein. Dann hast du halt schon viele Fälle,
wo das zwar grundsätzlich richtig ist, aber aufgrund von Timing Problemen oder anderen Dingen einfach äh nicht
so out of the Box funktioniert. Das heißt, du musst halt irgendwie mehr Varianten machen und
ist die Situation halt noch, noch viel schlimmer. So, da passieren halt
viel mehr Fehler, mit denen man auch rechnen muss, da passieren Vorgänge bei unterschiedlichen Temperaturen auf andere Art und Weise. Also es ist halt schon bisschen äh Tricky sozusagen so eine,
jetzt mit Hilfe von,
RNA äh zu programmieren. Aber es gibt mittlerweile auch da eine eine riesengroße Szene seit Jahren. Es gibt jede Menge Open Source äh RNA äh und also eigentlich,
kann man ja kann man,
heutzutage auch dann im Internet, selbst wenn du kein äh Genprinter hast, kannst du dir halt da deine Gene zusammenpacken, schickst das letztes dann hoch und kriegst dann ein paar Tage oder eine Woche später kriegst du dann halt deine,
RNA oder DNA, äh Sequenz, die du dann bestellt hast, die du dir dann und kannst dann halt damit rumspielen. Ähm ja.
Sehr schön fand ich auch noch, dass am Ende dieser Sequenz,
Also diese MRNA, die muss ja auch irgendwo ein Ende haben. Muss ja alle und und äh tatsächlich endet RNA mit ganz viel äh.
Wie man so schön sagt, das ist dann äh Pulli äh Pulli, Adinny lated, äh das bedeutet, dass da sozusagen das A sich äh ganz viel befindet, also mit anderen Worten.
Hier so schön so. This is a fancy way of saine it ins on the lot of ah, ev,
M RNE, Hessen, Hessen.
Ja, also super Artikel, wenn ihr nur so äh auch nur Ansatzweisen plant von Programmierungen habt oder ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal äh also es ist wirklich eine sehr schöne Artikel, um überhaupt erstmal zu verstehen, wie funktioniert unser
Replikationssystem an der Stelle, wie funktioniert das mit R und A an sich? Wie funktioniert konkret dieser Virus und an welchen Stellen ist hier wirklich auch ähm Interessantes geleistet worden.
Ähm kann ich nur empfehlen, ist äh ein tolles toller Artikel.
Genau und wenn man, wie gesagt, bei äh gibt's gibt's halt schöne Projekte äh auch äh so was weiß ich und dann,
Ikolibakterien, Leuchten lassen kannst oder äh ja deine Scheiße nach Banane riechen äh lassen kannst und so äh
oder im Dunkel leuchten, so all das äh ja äh kann man halt äh ja
mittlerweile auch zu Hause machen, wenn man ich sehe, ich sehe zwar, dass da Leute, die das jetzt hören, dass so
wie einfach zu Hause so äh ja jetzt im Grunde genommen Genhacking äh betreiben äh kannst.
Aber was mich da so ein bisschen beruhigt an der Stelle ist, dass auch die Natur.
Normalerweise schon so, dass maximal tödliche Versucht hervorzubringen, was man sich nur vorstellen kann. Also es ist extrem schwierig irgendwas zu bauen,
gefährlicher ist als das, was die Natur so so hinbekommt, insofern ja äh aber klar.
Ist halt schon eine eine mächtige Geschichte. Und im Gegensatz zu.
Sagen muss, sowas jetzt normale Programmierer machen, ist die Biologie eher,
nutzt so Techniken, wie sie so Demoprogramierer auch nutzen, so nach dem Motto, wie packe ich möglichst viel Funktionalität in vier Kilobeit.
Source Code rein mit allen möglichen Tricks, dass zum Beispiel.
Bestimmte Kurzsequenzen teilweise dann auch ineinander verschoben sind. Das heißt, je nachdem, wo du anfängst zu lesen, bedeuten sie was anderes und sind quasi so ein bisschen komprimiert,
auch
so die die Gensequenzen, in dem halt die ineinander geschoben sind und mit den ganzen Start und Stoppsequenzen und so äh kann man da halt viel machen. Also ja, das heißt.
So typischerweise eben auch so natürliche RNA ist halt nicht so straight fordert der der Source Code, sondern das ist halt ganz schön gehackt wie eine ja wie so eine vier K oder sechzehn K äh.
Aus der Demoszene.
Gut, ähm noch ein äh Hinweis, da findet ihr zwei A
äh zwei Links in den Shownotes. Ähm und zwar ein Artikel bei Wild und äh
die beide äh genau auf diese Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler zielen, die jetzt hier äh nebenbei schon so über Bande erwähnt wurden, also die, die sozusagen diese
nennenswerten Durchbrüche in der MRNA-Forschung, die,
das ermöglicht haben, dass so ein Impfstoff überhaupt erst gebaut werden kann, auf der einen Seite, beziehungsweise, dass eben auch,
der Impfstoff genau in dieser Kodierung so gegen saß funktioniert. Äh auf der anderen Seite, dass es da ganz gut beleuchtet worden, welche äh Hürden die so hätten äh haben nehmen müssen. Und es wird dann auch, glaube ich, nicht ganz so Unrecht
vermutet, dass äh
oder mehrere Personen aus diesem Dunstkreis so in die engere Auswahl glaube ich für einen der Listenmedizinischen Nobelpreise reinfällt, weil es macht gerade so schwer den Eindruck, dass
diese ganze MA Impfstoffforschung wirklich.
Kandidat, wir haben ja hier auch schon drüber gesprochen, auch im Kontext diese,
Alpha folgt Geschichte davon Google, dass dass wir hier sozusagen kurz davor sind, so eine weitere medizinische Revolution zu erleben. Also das ist jetzt wirklich auch ein extrem katalysischen Effekt haben kann.
Und dazu darauf wollte ich jetzt auch nochmal am Schluss äh eingehen.
Ähm auch hier auf Basis eines Artikels, den ich äh entdeckt habe äh im New York Magazine.
Mit dem schönen Titel Wehhead the wexin the hole Time,
Ähm jetzt hast du's wahrscheinlich schon Shownotes gesehen, Pavel, ne? Aber wenn ich dich jetzt gefragt hätte.
Ne? Mhm.
Wann gab es den Impfstoff? Wann gab es den funktionierenden Impfstoff gegen Saas, Kopf zwei, das erste Mal.
Ab wann existierte das Ding.
Gut, jetzt habe ich's auch gelesen. Ich hätte so geschätzt, dass das eine,
paar Wochen, nachdem man das Virus sequenziert äh hat, die ich geschätzt habe, vielleicht einen Monat nach der Sequenzierung äh so ähm ja.
Und das stimmt auch insofern, als das nach einem Monat nach der Sequenzierung dieser Impfschufe tatsächlich auch bereits vorlag. Und zwar als Impfstoff,
als anwendbarer tatsächlich existierender physikalischer zu impfen, dazu spritzender Impfstoff,
Aber das Design für diesen Impfstoff nach der Sequenzierung lag nach zwei Tagen vor, genauer am dreizehnten Januar zwanzig zwanzig oder anders ausgerüstet vor einem Jahr.
Und äh am elften Januar wurde halt diese Sequenzierung des Saaskopf zwei das erste Mal bekannt gegeben worden aus China und dann haben sie sich halt irgendwie alle gleich rangesetzt und sie wussten insofern schon alle was zu tun ist, als das eben,
Grundsätzlich im RNA-Impfstoffe, das ist jetzt sozusagen,
zwar neu in dem Sinne als dass wir jetzt alle daraus einen Impfstoff bekommen, aber es war nicht neu, als das noch nie ein Impfstoff äh gegeben hätte, der halt bloß noch nie in dieser Phase drei Trails äh reinkam, haben wir auch schon öfter diskutiert, das halt im Wesentlichen ein Geldproblem
Und von daher wussten sie, was zu tun ist und zusammen mit diesen ähm Erkenntnissen, wie zum Beispiel dieser Trick, mit dem, wie kriegt man das,
Protein hin, dass es sich auch ohne den Virus richtig faltet, damit's noch genauso erkannt wird, plus eben dieses, wie muss man ein MRNA im Stoff so kodieren, dass er eben auch vom Körper angenommen wird. All diese Informationen
gab es zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon oder kamen innerhalb kürzester Zeit auch zusammen. Ja und das bedeutet, dass wir im Prinzip.
Theoretisch, ja? Hätte man im Februar zwanzig zwanzig anfangen können zu impfen. Theoretisch.
Oder sagen dann in Zukunft sagen wenn wir wissen okay wie, wie, wie.
Funktioniert's und das heißt das ist ja also so wie es aussieht, ich mein elfte Januar steht da Sequenzierung, dreizehnte Januar,
war's auf dem Papier äh fertig äh der der Impfstoff gehe ich mal davon aus, dass sie einfach nur ähm.
Eine Sequenz, die für das Protein zuständig sind äh war ausgetauscht haben oder entsprechend transferiert haben und der ganze Rest das Ganze drum rum
eigentlich unverändert geblieben ist oder oder das Ganze drumrum hat halt zehn oder zwanzig oder fünfzig Jahre gedauert, je nachdem wo man den den Beginn äh setzt.
Genau und und durch diese hochprogrammatische Art und Weise ist er immer nah, dass im Prinzip alles nur noch darauf basiert ist, man sagt, okay, der der Stoff wird nicht.
In der Fabrik erzeugt, sondern wir erzeugen in der Fabrik nichts anderes als diesen Programmcode, legen den in so eine Lipidhülle rein und dann geben wir denen den Körper und dieses Protein, was dann erkannt werden soll,
erzeugt der Körper selbst. Andere Impfstoffe haben anders funktioniert, dann wurden diese Proteine erzeugt, auch solche sind äh derzeit in Entwicklung.
Haben natürlich dementsprechend auch äh größere Nebenwirkungen gehabt oder waren nicht ganz so effizient oder haben auf jeden Fall länger gedauert oder sind eben schwieriger zu produzieren oder teurer. Und jetzt äh sind natürlich die Preise noch relativ hoch, weil das ist ja auch alles noch neues Zeug,
auch absehbar, dass sich das dann irgendwie in Zukunft ändern wird, aber wir haben hier eine Methodik, die ähm im Prinzip jetzt danach
viel Zeit für Sachen äh verwendet hat, die eigentlich schon,
klar war, das heißt, alle Wissenschaftler, das geht so aus dem Artikel auch hervor, waren halt so ja, also wir sind die ganze Zeit davon ausgegangen, dass es funktioniert,
Also keiner hatte irgendwie wirklich so Zweifel. Man war natürlich am Ende auch froh, als man das dann auch belegen konnte. Aber diese vorgeschriebene Prozedur
Phase eins, erstmal im Labor nachweisen, ja, kann geimpft werden, gibt keine Auswirkungen, wir haben das jetzt äh an so einem kleinen Kreis von freiwilligen getestet,
alles dann Phase zwei das Ganze sozusagen auch schon wirklich jetzt über diese reine klinische Studie hinaus dann schon in der größeren Gruppe bis man dann eben die Erlaubnis bekommt für Phase drei
dann eben mit vierzigtausend, dreißigtausend Teilnehmern in größeren Mengen nachweisen, okay, im Vergleich zur Placebo-Gruppe, wirkt auch, hilft auch und so weiter.
Nur es ist halt so, dass jetzt in diesen Wissenschaftlerkreisen so die Überzeugung existiert.
Dass dass das sozusagen einfach alles gar nicht mehr so nötig wäre.
Dass also diese Phase eins schon so ein bisschen
Ähm na ja, muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt immer wieder neu machen, weil das wird sich für die zu erwartende Virusbedrohung der Zukunft, wenn wird sich das nicht so grundsätzlich ändern,
Und es gibt jetzt einfach Überlegungen, wie man's anders macht und tatsächlich wird es ja auch heutzutage schon anders gemacht. Wenn man mal schaut, wie mit Influencer umgegangen wird.
Die Grippeimpfung ist so eine Art vorauswette.
Also man impft quasi gegen Viren, von dem man glaubt, dass sie kommen. Man betrachtet das Mutationsgeschehen in der Influenza-Welt.
Macht daraufhin eine eine Voraussage, welche Mutation vermutlich.
Am meisten Verbreitungen gefunden haben werden und gibt die Kodierung um gegen diese Vira eine Ausprägung vorzugehen die gibt man in diesen Impfstoff rein.
Aber man fängt jetzt nicht komplett wieder mit so einer Phase eins und so weiter an und testet das in großen Mengen, sondern man sagt einfach
Guck mal hier, grundsätzlich, um mit Influencer-Viren umzugehen, haben wir hier diese Plattform, diesen Baukasten, in dem wir nur den und den und den Informationen ändern
Und dann geben wir das raus und impfen das irgendwie massenhaft zu den Leuten, damit es auch noch rechtzeitig ankommt. Und das ist ja ein Wunder, man hat jedes Jahr sozusagen so eine neue äh Gesamtmischung mit,
mit einer Wette quasi da drauf, was ist und in manchen Jahren funktioniert's besser und in manchen Jahren funktioniert's nicht so gut, je nachdem wie gut diese Vorhersage funktioniert hat,
Und der Artikel argumentiert jetzt oder der Artikel, sondern die Wissenschaftler, die dort befragt werden, argumentieren, ähm.
Und da gibt's auch äh einen Paper von dem Florian Krammer,
die ich hier schon mal äh zitiert habe, der diesen wunderbaren äh Online-Vortrag da gehalten hat, so wie das eben alles funktioniert und was äh von der Sicherheit des Impfstoffs zu halten ist,
der im Prinzip sagt wir könnten in Zukunft grundsätzlich ganz anders mit all dem umgehen. Man könnte sagen.
Lasst uns einfach Kohle zusammenwerfen. Man braucht, um diese Phase eins zu machen für einen bestimmten Impfstoff,
Vielleicht zu zwanzig bis dreißig Millionen Dollar. Ja? Damit hat man dann sozusagen schon mal,
diesen Test durchgeführt und gesagt OK alles klar in dieser konkreten Ausprägungsform gegen diese Art von Virus,
wir so im Prinzip einen Impfstoff auf den Weg bringen. Und das könnte man heute schon für fünfhundert bis äh für fünfzig bis einhundert Viren machen.
Also bestimmte Virenarten.
Das ja und es sei relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass es einen bedrohlichen Virus gibt, deren Basis man heute eigentlich noch gar nicht kennt. Das heißt, man weiß eigentlich, womit man's zu tun hat, ja? Corona, Viren, in verschiedenen Ausprägungen,
wir wissen, was der Feind ist. Wir wissen nur eben nicht, in welcher finalen, bedrohlichen Form das nächste Mal äh es wieder richtig wild wird.
Aber man kann im Prinzip.
Technisch betrachtet gegen die Art, jetzt schon die Grundlage legen und das Geld schon vorher ausgeben, sprich würde man jetzt diese alle fünfzig bis hundert Viren mal eben einfach mal so äh die Phase eins machen,
hätte die Welt so ungefähr ein bis drei Milliarden Dollar ausgegeben und dann lege im Prinzip die Plattform zur Bekämpfung so von so ziemlich allen denkbaren Virusangriffen
schon im Regal und könnte dann innerhalb kürzester Zeit, sprich innerhalb von Wochen ähm einen passenden Impfstoff entwickeln und den dann auch auf den Weg.
Wenn man das jetzt dann noch mit meiner Idee, weiß nicht, von vom letzten Mal, ob ich die da schon geäußert hatte, nämlich.
Dass man halt auch generell äh Virus oder generell Pathoggensequenzierung hm offenen,
neuen Level hebt, dass man statt wie wir es jetzt machen irgendwie fünf Corona Viren am Tag, dass man halt wirklich großflächig so sagen beobachtet.
Was tut sich eigentlich und äh dort eben auch um Sequenzierung vornimmt, dass man dann überhaupt auch frühzeitig erkennen kann, wenn da was Neues auftaucht und sich ausbreitet, wozu wir im Moment gar nicht in der Lage sind.
Also zumindest nicht in Deutschland.
Nicht in, nicht in Deutschland, ja, aber selbst jetzt in anderen Ländern, selbst wenn wir, wenn man's jetzt ums Hundertfache, äh, also man müsste es eigentlich nochmal, ich sag mal, ein, zwei Größenordnungen mehr äh machen, so, dass man.
Halt äh einfach komplett
man es gibt ja auch dieses Screening im im Moment, was auch vom vom RKI äh gemacht wird auf einen Haufen Infektionskrankheiten, wo
einfach 'n Haufen Ärzte, Praxen mitarbeiten, wenn die 'ne Blutprobe entnehmen, schicken die davon dann auch 'n Teil dann ans,
RKI wo dann diese Studie.
Gemacht wird, aber das sagen einfach nochmal on Steroits, das Ganze nochmal Faktor hundert oder tausend, dass man
sagen komplett äh einfach mal Infektionskrankheiten
auf einer ganz ganz anderen Ebene begegnet, als wir das im Moment tun und dass man halt dann auch vielleicht sogar mit Grippe und Schnupfen und mit was auch immer äh.
Wir da attackiert werden, äh jedes jedes Jahr, dass man das wirklich zuverlässig äh oder.
Mit einer ganz anderen Intensität äh bekämpft und mit ganz anderer Technik als wir das bisher tun.
Ja und vor allem für sehr viel äh effizienter, ne? Also ich meine so drei Milliarden Dollar klingt jetzt erstmal nach einer Menge Geld, aber das ist natürlich was so Panemie betrifft äh Bekämpfung betrifft, ist es
wie nix, ich meine, allein die USA hat äh das viertausendfache davon ausgegeben, um allein diese Pandemie zu bekämpfen,
Das ist natürlich ein relativ klarer Deal. Ähm was nicht heißt, dass ich damit rechnet, dass es auf jeden Fall so kommen wird. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall der Punkt äh
welche Richtung man jetzt wahrscheinlich arbeiten sollte, dass man einfach das ganze systemischer angeht und äh vielleicht nicht nur, aber vor allem
der Kraft dieser MRNA-Technologie hier voranschreitet und vielleicht einfach mal das Thema Panimin äh für die nächsten Jahre mal so komplett abschaltet.
Und da ist ja Zeit, spielt da halt die Rolle und ich rechne auch damit, dass es da wahrscheinlich Änderungen
geben wird in den Zulassungen und wie man das alles alles handhabt. Und ja, meine interessante Erkenntnis, das ist, das war mir tatsächlich nicht nicht klar, dass,
wenn es so etwas schon Anfang des Jahres gegeben hätte, dass wir dann im Prinzip,
ja ab März oder April hätten mit dem Impfen beginnen können und jetzt eigentlich durch wären.
Ja, die Schätzung lag super dann bei der, bei drei Monaten, also der Florian äh erster Florian äh Grammer hat dann auch vorgeschlagen.
Man könnte zum Beispiel auch diese Phase drei gegebenenfalls in Zukunft überspringen, indem man so im Labor mit Antigen.
Testet und das gibt einfach Möglichkeiten all diese ganzen Phasen zu verkürzen.
Obwohl ja jetzt schon alles extrem verkürzt worden ist, im Vergleich, wie es normalerweise abläuft, ja, aber so die Perspektive von es dauert fünf Jahre, bis irgendwie ein Impfstoff gefunden ist und in dem Moment, wo er,
auf der Welt aufschlägt, ist er eigentlich nur noch dazu gut, umso das letzte, die letzte Glut auszutreten, nachdem eigentlich der der Virus schon alles abgemäht hat, so wie wir das jetzt derzeit.
Auch sehen in Deutschland, ja? Also es wird einfach Landkreise geben, denke ich mal Ende dieses Jahres, wo.
Fünfzig Prozent könnte jetzt irgendeine Zahl aus der Nase ziehen, aber auf jeden Fall viel zu viel Prozent aller Leute,
infiziert worden sind, ja? Ich mein wir haben jetzt diesen einen Landkreis mit irgendwie den Erzgebirge hat halt irgendwie fünf Prozent, jetzt nimmst du halt mal da eine Dunkelziffer von
was weiß ich, drei bis fünf. So, dann sind wir halt schon mal äh fast bei bei zwanzig äh Prozent und jetzt
läuft das Ganze nochmal ein paar Wochen und ein paar Monate so weiter.
Dann kannst du halt nachimpfen und sagen so Leute jetzt ist auch sichergestellt, es ist nicht widerkriegt, aber ihr habt's jetzt alle äh gehabt und,
dieser Ansatz das einfach generell anders zu entwickeln, zu sagen Phase eins ist so Plattformvorbereitung für alle erdenklichen Virus
Varianten oder Virustypen in einer bestimmten Gruppe und wir wissen einfach, wie wir das angehen und wenn's soweit ist
Wir rasen schnell durch diese Phasen durchgehen ohne jetzt groß in der Sicherheit Abstriche zu machen und haben am Ende sehr viel billiger und sehr viel schneller eine Reaktion und können auch wirklich äh eine aufflammende Panimie innerhalb von,
drei Monaten aktiv angehen und damit dann auch äh sehr effektiv abtöten.
Das wäre sagen eine sehr positive Folge dann von dieser Pandimie Erfahrung, wenn,
ja das so passiert und es werden dann auch die Produktionskapazitäten da sein und das Know-How nimmt ja auch ständig zu und ja eigentlich.
Ja 'ne, 'ne positive Geschichte. Das Einzige.
Positive Geschichte wieder äh umdrehen. Ich wollte jetzt gerade einen schönen positiv ins Jahr starten.
.
Okay, aber ein ein äh ja, ein Kaviar äh muss ich dann trotz der der nein.
Damit auch in den Griff zu kriegen wäre, aber wir haben's ja noch nicht,
die neue Schnellzulassung von Impfstoffen, nämlich das ganze Motationsthema äh macht mir halt äh.
Aktuell ein bisschen sagen, weil wir hatten ja anfangs war ja eher so die Drostenen Entwarnung, ah das ist ein stabiles Virus, da müssen wir uns erstmal bis auf Weiteres über Montationen,
Ähm keine großen Gedanken machen, aber das war halt wahrscheinlich.
Richtig im April oder im März so, aber mittlerweile bei den großen.
Infizierten Zahlen dadurch, dass man's halt weltweit so hat hochkochen lassen, haben wir natürlich jetzt im Moment äh noch.
Ja, ein riesen Mutationspotential wie man sieht und.
Dass wir und da hoffe ich, dass uns das jetzt nicht noch in die Quere kommt und unseren ganzen Zeitplan übern Haufen äh äh wirft, weil wir dann wieder,
vorsichtiger oder zögernder reagieren als das bisher der Fall ist. Auf der anderen Seite.
Man weiß so eine Katastrophe oder ein Unfall,
schwerwiegende Folgen hat, kann natürlich auch Leute abschrecken, sich impfen zu lassen. Das heißt, es ist halt immer schon, ja.
Vorsichtig sein, aber grundsätzlich erstmal denke ich auch, das ganze Impfstoffthema sehr erfreulich ähm so diese.
Fortschritte, die da erzielt worden sind und äh ja können nur hoffen.
Dass uns ja die Mutter jetzt nicht irgendwie noch den Plan über den Haufen werfen.
Ja, ich habe keine Angst vor die Mutter dazu. Das wird schon werden. Also es äh hat sich alles so alles so stabil äh äh herausgestellt und die Aussage von dem Schall hin so nach dem Motto, ja, wenn das Ding irgendwie ein bisschen motiert, dann.
Code aus, dann ist in sechs Wochen das neu produzierte den neu produzierte Impfstoff dagegen auch funktionabel. Das.
Das ist das, genau, das das.
In der Praxis, also dass das sagen technisch biologisch funktionieren würde, glaube ich, aber wir sehen.
Liegen viele Probleme nicht äh an der an der Biotechnologie, sondern an den administrativen Prozessen außen drum und äh ja das ist das, wo ich mir.
Sagen mehr Sorgen mache, dass wenn so eine Mutation auftritt, dass es passieren könnte, dass dann ja es doch länger dauert, nicht aus technischen Gründen, sondern aus.
Äh aus bürokratischen Gründen. Ja.
Bürokratischen Gründen, weil keine Ahnung Verträge für den Impfstoff jetzt da sind und man die jetzt nicht dann einfach auf einen anderen Impfstoff äh äh übertragen kann oder irgend so ein Quatsch, ja.
Nee, die müsste ich jetzt erst von den alten Impfstoff äh äh abnehmen äh wie auch äh immer, keine Ahnung.
Äh Faxgeräte.
Ich mein da wird es Lösungen für geben aber mein meine Befürchtung ist einfach nur, dass da halt durch diese Friktion oder dass das durch bürokratische Friktion ähm sagen äh,
es nicht so optimal laufen könnte, wie es eigentlich laufen kann.
Okay, gut, Pavel, jetzt hast du genug negative Energie hier in meinen potenziellen Abspann reingebracht. Das hat sich gerade so schön die Stimmung aufgebaut,
äh zukunftsvoll und hoffnungsfroh in zwanzig einundzwanzig durchzustarten? Jetzt hast du noch eine Minute die Gelegenheit das Ding selber umzud.
Alles wird gut, alles wird, alles wird gut, äh so und äh ja.
Mehr kann man dazu nicht sagen.
Mehr kann man dazu nicht sagen. Äh.
Jetzt haben wir nämlich zu allem schon viel zu viel gesagt, wir haben hier fast drei Stunden voll gequatscht mit dieser Sendung. Ich bereite derzeit sehr intensiv irgendwie äh äh alles vor, indem ich mir möglichst viel anschaue und habe immer Angst, ich kriege die Sendung nicht voll und jetzt,
schon übervoll, aber falls ihr äh interessante Sachen habt, gibt's äh.
Letztes Kamp, ich möchte gern auf alles hingewiesen werden, was vielleicht potenziell mal interessant wäre. Das meiste fliegt einem auf Twitter ohnehin schon äh zu, aber andere Kanäle, aber ich bin da nach wie vor
interessiert, weil stelle auch fest, umso mehr man sich damit beschäftigt.
Umso interessanter wird das. Das ist wirklich, was ich alles schon gelernt habe äh in diesem Jahr äh diesem letzten zwölf Monaten ähm erstaunlich.
Habe ich äh von vielen keine Ahnung gehabt vorher.
Es hilft jemand, dass da überhaupt auch der Grund, warum wir damit angefangen haben, aber warum ich erstmal damit
angefangen habe, weil mir das halt Angst gemacht hat, weil ich nicht verstanden habe, was denn da jetzt auf uns zukommt und was denn da losgeht und das
hilft schon oder hat, hat halt schon sehr geholfen so die Zahlen zu verstehen im im Blick zu behalten und das Ganze drum rum zu zu bewerten und so und ja
Also.
Deswegen werden wir das jetzt auch weiterhin tun.
Und äh jetzt warten wir erstmal ab, bis nächste Woche bis äh die richtigen Zahlen kommen und dann wissen wir auch, ob äh welche
von Dooms Day Szenario wir dann so für
Januar und Februar und März entwickeln. Ich merke schon so in der Allgemeinheit ähm äh auch in der Politik zeichnet sich langsam ab, so, dass sie schon so sehen so, na ja, am besten können wir gleich den Empfehlungen von UKW folgen und so.
Wird's schon dauern, denke ich mir mal so, ja, weil hatten wir schon im Podcast.
Also die Schulöffnungsdebatte wird halt wieder unschön werden oder die ist ja schon unschön.
Das wird uns schön werden. Ja, sehr.
Schön geworden und ja ich hoffe aber ich hoffe auch, dass diesmal ja nicht wieder äh so ein Unsinn gemacht wird wie.
In früheren Phasen oder in den letzten Monaten, so wo wir definitiv.
Wir haben ja ein neues Jahr Pavel, alles wird gut und das bedeutet auch diese Debatten werden besser ich hoffe auch die Podcasts werden immer besser und ja an dieser Stelle machen wir jetzt einfach mal ein Cut und äh sagen schön tschüss.
Ja, tschüss und ja bleibt gesund.
Und lasst euch nicht runterkriegen und wir hören uns dann äh in der nächst.